ah probably do an ah montage one day
like a fast cut because it's like it's
the beginning of
every [ __ ] trash taste podcast it's
one of us going
i'm waiting for the day that someone
just like samples all of our audience
just makes like a lo-fi beat out of it
do it
hello and welcome to trash chase the
anime podcast where we talk about japan
food [ __ ] and occasionally anime i
am your host for today
and with me are the boys
i was just like what is the tagline that
could go well with trash tape i mean
that sounds about right like that's
probably the most accurate
the the anime podcast anime podcast
but uh how are you guys doing how are
you boys doing
since last week we spoke about claymore
and i was like [ __ ] it i'll read
claymore
and it was really good you literally
just finished it like yeah two minutes
but to be fair if you haven't read
claymore and anything about it don't
worry about it you don't need to know
anything uh
manga is good until about halfway and
then it kind of just goes a bit [ __ ]
second yeah it's definitely yeah yeah
yeah i feel like a lot of anime and
manga
do this where they build up like this
[ __ ] amazing world that i think is
too big of a scope and then they just
like [ __ ] we need to finish this like
within like 200 chapters
how do we do that yeah well i think for
a lot of the times at least with like
shaun and jump because klamas from
shannon jump yeah a lot of the times the
authors don't really have a choice as to
how long it goes for
right i i feel like shonen jump goes
through the same problem
as you know a lot of american tv shows
where
you know you have some like rare like
something like breaking bad for example
it's like a rarity where
a show just gets better it hits its peak
and then it stops
you know what i mean but the problem
with that comes along yeah
but that's more like a spin-off right
yeah i think medical school's better
than breaking bad
okay oh okay yo you're one of your
the problem with a lot of it like shown
in john manga is that they most of the
time they either go on for
too short or they get dragged out do you
either you're either like a bleach
or you are something that gets cancelled
early like most other shonen jump shows
yeah that's the thing is right is that
like with shine and jump they have
every month they have rankings right
yeah you have even just a slight dip in
popularity
then they're kind of just like well time
to wrap it up boyo
and the author's like well i i i just i
just got started it doesn't matter
i gotta wrap it up i wonder if that's
what happened but to be fair
when i was reading this it's 150
chapters around like the 80th is i was
like ah yeah this isn't going to end
like great
it ended which is better than most well
i mean you know yeah it's better than
like what happened to like you hawk show
right yeah
oh yeah yeah well like the last actors
got completely [ __ ] gutted
i mean you can tell when when an author
just like has to wrap things up in five
chapters or something yeah just like
yeah yeah some some some stuff that
they've been building up for like 100 to
200 chapters just gets wrapped up in ten
chapters and you're like
what the [ __ ] was this and then there's
like the opposite of that
with uh what's the mangaka for hunter
hunter called
where he introduces like the dark
continent when he can't [ __ ] make one
chapter
and he's like how about i just expand
the world tenfold i uh i tweeted out
about it the other day but i found out
the other day that
in the span that it took togashi to
release chapter volume 32-33
assassination classrooms started and
ended oh my god
so if you don't know hunter hunter has
been on hiatus not hiatus
basically we get a chapter like once
every two years no it's definitely a
hiatus
yeah yeah yeah we got a chapter once
over two years hxh is short for hiatus
what counts as a hiatus nowadays is it
like a hunter hunter hiatus or a
berserk murderer you know what i mean i
mean they're kind of the same thing
it's just like maybe it's just a very
slow release schedule
do you know what i mean sure sure but uh
have you seen some of hunter hunter's
latest chapters have you seen some of
the dark continent chapters yeah
i i've i've i've read i've seen like
some of the later chapters and
some of them are just literally there
are pages that are just all text
there's like one character and it's
literally
it's just a full page of text and at
this point i'm just like
takashi if you want to write a light
novel just write the lighting obviously
man this manga
is just somehow like writing a book
without realizing it i don't know
i mean he is kind of releasing volumes
on the schedule of like
light novel exactly he's like why why
why are we pretending that this is a
manga anymore you know what i mean
and like the drawings oh my god yeah
yeah
it's like someone on devan art man just
do it already like what's going on
what i want to know is like because i
don't think togashi
uses assistance uh maybe probably not
i mean probably not because if not
assumptions you'd think that you get
assistance to draw right his wife oh
well yeah his wife is the author of
sound oh [ __ ]
on his wife yeah
one of the greatest jojo manga authors
of all time i listen
to hunter if you haven't read or seen it
just do it it's amazing but just
prepared
for just i see okay so here's the thing
i haven't
read hunter hunter at all yeah but i
have all of the volumes up until this
point yeah okay dude honestly watch the
anime the anime is so [ __ ] good yeah
no
the anime is great it's one of the few
anime that i think is
better than the manga yeah really and
that's because
the 2011 version yeah the 2011 version
because some of the later
uh like arcs especially the chimera
antarc um
tagashi's arc is really up and down
right because of
you know his health complications that
he was going through but like the anime
is just consistent throughout so anyone
who doesn't know
i would i would recommend and recommend
because i know so much about
the series like of like characters and
like man
yeah i know so many references but i've
never actually sat down and read or
watched it
yeah i think i think i think i know
enough about naruto to like
to like line my way through a
conversation being like oh yeah the leaf
there's like
crazy i could probably lie my way
through a full metal alchemist
translation i have that many times
just so sad bro i mean let's be real
like i feel we've all done that right
we're like
everyone around you is talking about an
anime and you're kind of just like yeah
yeah
yeah that thing for like for like five
years i was an anime fan who hadn't
watched evangelion people would be like
dude it's epic right i'm like yeah do
you like getting the robot
yeah my dad hates me
did that a little bit with um with
bleach
for all right insecure right yeah
because i i didn't i dropped it at uh
the eisenhocke
right so anything after that i had no
[ __ ] idea
but people around me kept reading it and
they were like yeah you know the whole
like wicca mundo stuff i was like yeah
that thing yeah that thing totally yeah
one of those anime or manga that you
could you could
feasibly lie your way out of it to make
it seem like you've seen it without
having seen it
after you've watched like a third the
first few arcs then you kind of just
kind of just can just [ __ ] your way
i too also want to see more bangkok
i feel like it's the same one piece
right because one piece is so long it's
like the simpsons right where everything
that could ever happen has probably
happened
so you could be like dude my favorite
episode is where like homer simpson
becomes a crack addict that's probably
an episode of the simpsons right i mean
you could probably do that with one
piece right now because you're the only
one who hasn't seen it so you could just
randomly be like yeah i love that
episode where luffy and um
chopper make out i love the epic i love
the part where
the pirates find another band of pirates
that are bad initially and then
turn and are part of some military and
then they're like dude let's just be
good
let's help luffy out right oh yeah the
water seminar is
that was vague enough that if i keep it
vague right that could be about
four different arcs in one piece yes i
know enough base information about one
piece i still haven't read it yet again
i downloaded some episodes some chapters
on my phone
but maybe maybe one so you so you're
downloading a lot of chapters now i see
no i have like i have like 10 volumes
downloaded which is as much
how far into i i don't [ __ ] know
because we're approaching what volume
100
of one piece we're approaching a chapter
a thousand i think aren't we which is
going to be a landmark
and yeah a thousand chapters that's uh
can you imagine [ __ ] a thousand every
week a thousand chapters i cannot
[ __ ] imagine that's a thousand weeks
at least minimum because what is he
married the author
i think so i think it's kind of
interesting to be the fact-checker yeah
it's
interesting actually because
i feel like you can't be married and
make one piece
like it's pick one well it's so
interesting because like i feel
not obviously he is married okay so
because like not a whole lot about oda
is even known yeah because he so rarely
makes any like
tv appearances or like interview
appearances because he's too busy
[ __ ] writing a chapter a week right
he's not just doing that because oda out
of every author is way more involved in
the anime production as well right
because normally he was produced right
yeah yeah with normally a lot of anime
productions people were just like
okay there's the author and then the
author just gets sidelined and they just
continue doing that stuff and maybe
they'll watch the anime you know
but you know oda has been involved in a
lot of the anime production which
i don't where does he find the time to
do this i don't know
i like this man is like a time
management machine as a shown in jump
author
i don't know how you can have a life
like most authors don't have a life
outside of
their magazine i mean most of them have
health complications because of how much
they work
not to mention that like i swear with
every new chapter oda's art is just
evolving
like it's getting more like some of the
recent chapters are so
[ __ ] detailed yeah how do you draw
this in a week yeah exactly
like people like to piss on one piece
character designs because oh it looks
cartoonish looks challenging they look
[ __ ] weird
they they do look weird yeah but at
least it's like so distinct to the point
where you can look at a character and be
like oh yeah that's a one piece
character
yeah yeah true but you said about
simpsons but you don't have
a family guy maybe but i would argue
that like that's better than
a [ __ ] generic ass looking character
that could fit into any
yeah like you know or any one of oda's
character designs is way more memorable
than
his generic isekai protagonist number 75
that looks like kirito
just re-skinned yeah you know what i
mean like that's that's what i think i
think that's my biggest problem with a
lot of light novel adaptations is that
you can tell light enough adaptations
nowadays by just by just the characters
how they look i'm just the art styles
right
yeah because the character designs
haven't changed from like 10 years yeah
i know right it's like good looking boy
with average proportions with uh spiky
hair
color it in exact color there you go
like even even a lot of like the girls
as well because i i think one
like one is pink haired character like
one of my favorites uh one of my
favorite female characters to come out
of recent times is uh my sakurajima from
bunnygirl's empire yeah
and like i really liked all of the cast
there and all of the characters but
my god they have such forgettable
character design yes you know what i
mean compared to
some of some of the character signs from
say like monogatari or something like
that
yeah which you know it gets compared to
compared to lots and i see the same
charm but
in terms of the memorability of the
character designs it's just bunny girl's
empire just looks like
the most generic well i mean that's why
that's only
one of the reasons i just didn't watch
it yeah that's why they had to put it in
a bunny costume right
between all the other characters exactly
and because there's a lot of anime
characters just like silhouette or eyes
right you can just
know right and like you know i would
argue again like that's i think one of
the strong suits about one piece right
is that like because the
characters look so [ __ ] wacky you can
immediately tell that's a one-piece
character yeah
and it's the the way i describe oda is
it it's some it
it's like you're reading a story with
from someone who has the imagination
of a ten-year-old but the writing skills
of like joe are martin or something like
that yeah you know what i mean it's
it's so weird because you see a
character like this
cross-dressing ballerina for example
yeah and you're like what is this wacky
character
yeah yeah yeah uh mr two so yeah mr two
yeah
yeah i always get the numbers it's the
two bonnie clay summer yeah mr
mr green eggs and hamburglar i love that
but you see his character design for the
first time and you just like this i'm
never gonna give a [ __ ] about this
character
and then he ends up in later arcs
bringing you to tears sometimes and just
like
how did this happen how how did he make
how did oda
make me care about this person right now
that you can see on screen yeah anyone
who hasn't watched one piece is probably
looking at this being like
what is this clown who is this literal
cloud you know what i mean
that's your that's your your weekly jack
off to it's a one piece
segment of the pog yeah as we're going
to do every week now
we're going to do every week until you
until you start reading it
if i read it we'll become a [ __ ]
one-piece podcast
it won't but it might become more of a
manga podcast
i'll spend like 20 hours reading a manga
my review will be like yeah sorry
so wait so what would you give out of 10
claymore six
six six i see really i don't want to
read
anyone else's reviews of manga at all i
don't want to know because i feel like
right now because i don't head out
because i don't i don't touch anything
with the reviews in terms of marketing i
don't know what the popular opinion is i
don't know if i should go into a thing
think it's good or bad i just see
something i'm like i'll read that and
make up my own choice
kind of like it that i'm in my own
bubble of like i don't give a [ __ ]
enough
what anyone else thinks it's weird right
because i feel like manga readers just
exist in their own bubbles right
because when we talk about the anime
community most people refer to it as
like the anime and manga community
it's it's we're we kind of we're kind of
we're kind of assumed that we're just
synonymous with each other right but
then there are times when i just kind of
realized that
i have no idea what's going on in the
manga world sometimes like
there's this recent uh there's this
airing anime right now called
horimia that's uh so good
yeah exactly exactly maelyn's just like
fangirling the mongoose favorite manga
[ __ ] awesome like
when the when the anime got is getting
adapted there was like so many manga
readers that was
they come out they just come back did
that just come out and
say oh my god this is my favorite manga
i [ __ ] love this mark
and here i am thinking where what is
this rock that you're all living under
what is this wrong
this is the thing right i say six out of
ten but i'm sure that they're like me
they're like i forget about it but when
the
the animes announced i'm like yo yo
that's my that's my [ __ ]
favorite i love that one i read that
ages ago i loved that
no because the thing is i had never
heard of horimia before the anime got
adapted
this winter season right and i'm just
like it must be a pretty like it must
have like a cult following or something
so
search it up and oh it has a cold
following and it is
the 13th most popular manga of all time
on my anime list and i'm just like how
if i haven't
how have i never heard this name before
or how has no one discussed this in my
presence before
i thought reading bad but that's the
thing that's what i find so interesting
about the manga world is that even if
it's like universally praised and
credited as being this most amazing
piece of work right in the manga world
it's just really surprising
how few people in the anime community
actually know about it like i guaran
[ __ ] tea
not many people know about like oyasumi
punpun even though i think it's like the
second or third highest rated manga yeah
i i feel like
i feel like i don't know some like seen
in manga you you have like the sane in
big four i think you have like finland
saga always the [ __ ] big numbers
it is because it's it's not quite the
medium
that that describes things pretty well
never mind we should we should rename it
like the gigaforce like the gigaforce
might be three i can't remember because
like it's it's which ones are you
referring to
you know you know like the crowd that
always talk about vinland saga
it's either villain saga berserk or uh
[ __ ] [ __ ] vagabond oh vagabond yeah
yeah yeah
i think there's one more that is in that
genre that everyone
keeps maybe golden camely no it's not
golden can we but
maybe it's just a big three maybe maybe
i'm just imagining things but there's
like i feel like a lot of sane in manga
gets talked about as like these
masterpieces you know what i mean but
some like slice of life romance manga
like holy mia that
is apparently very popular just don't
get talked about in the same sphere
and well i would argue that like even
the big the big three scene and that's
i guess we've coined it now like barely
a toys about like it
upsets me how few people know about like
vagabond
really yeah i feel like a lot of people
know about that i don't know about
vagabond
okay
i know it is a title that exists i know
absolutely nothing about it
so vagabond essentially is uh it's a
samurai manga
yeah um but i would but it's done by uh
the author who did slam dunk
oh yeah okay i mean that sounds cool so
you know where somehow not only managed
to make one of the greatest sports manga
ever made but also one of the greatest
samurai mangroves
yeah and it's [ __ ] amazing okay yeah
how many chapters is it
it's still going still ongoing it's on
hiatus but
it's i don't know what it is about this
you know the the brutal scene in manga
where the you get up to
like 200 or 300 chapters and the
author's just like i
i'ma head out i'm gonna take a break i
think like
at least the manga i've read it feels
like they build up like a really cool
world and again they just like it either
gets too big
yeah they're just like right we're gonna
reign this in yeah or like it just gets
way too big and it ends with like so
many [ __ ] things not
explored because because like going back
to hunter hunter like i
it got up to a point where i'm just like
this is a this is a comfortable place to
end it you know what i mean this
this is a comfortable place to like you
could try it yeah no it definitely could
have ended it right
and then she introduces the dark
continent which without spoiling
the exact details of it is so you have
no one's ever gonna see the end of it
you have this you have this world
that takashi build up in hunter hunter
right and it was like how how long was
like the run
whatever 148 episodes yeah 148 episodes
right and
it ended to a point where you explored
everything you needed to explore about
the world right and he went on hiatus
and everyone's just like oh you know
hunter hunter must be coming to an end
right and then he comes back and he's
just like
jk by the way this is just one fifth of
the world
yes i hate it when they do that man like
like don't don't
come here and pull that out of your ass
it's like a [ __ ] like
parody iphone presentation it's like but
wait
there's more it's like wait but no stop
stop there shouldn't be
more as cool as the idea is of like
expanding the world
it's honestly one of the things that
makes me roll my eyes the most when i've
been reading manga lately
is when they're like but there's another
consonant or planet and i'm like oh for
[ __ ] sake
there is not gonna be another planet
that is gonna be satisfied yeah that's
that's exactly how i felt when like uh
you know in like dragon ball when they
started expanding on like multiverses
i was like bruh i thought like i thought
like blowing up planets and like taking
over the universe was
hard enough and now it's like well uh
you know there's like seven more
universes out there that we can explore
nothing gets my
job like softer than hearing multiverse
or like expanding the
universe out of like i think the one
thing i hate the most is how like i
don't mind them like introducing that
kind of thing
if they actually follow you yeah yeah
but the problem is they just they'll
just drop it
in like a chapter they'll be like oh by
the way there's other worlds
no there wasn't there were never other
worlds you never made this manga with
other worlds in mind you liar you're
adding this now
like because like okay back sorry to
bring it up again for like the ninth
time but like
when i was reading claymore they just
casually mentioned like there's two
worlds having a war
and then it's like never brought up
again and then they just it just ends
and we
never hear anything about the other
world that's apparently having a war and
it's like whoa whoa whoa whoa so
everyone gets to go alone happy
but the whole reason why this world
exists is because there was a war and
this is like a testing
it's really [ __ ] like i don't i
don't like it when they do this
especially when
the manga is like you know it's been
going on for a long time
right and it already feels like it's
stretching thin and then they're like
another world baby
it's like no no no no no no because like
you said if they build it up
fine but yeah i just drop it i hate it
yeah yeah no you you sometimes see these
plot points and manga there's just like
dropped and
for some reason you just never never
hear about it again
like aside from other worlds the biggest
example i can think of
is the gantz manga oh my god well i love
that one but i was so dumb
yeah where i just like remember when
there were vampires in it
and that was a big plot point oh yeah
and then they just disappeared
yeah yeah i just would just never heard
about again there's a lot of stuff in
game
so if you haven't read gans um i guess
you could uh
it's very long it's really the artwork
is [ __ ] amazing we spoke about it
before but yeah
randomly halfway through they introduced
vampires into a world that never had
vampires
and then they just never come up again
not gonna lie like i barely remember any
of it because i think at that point i
kind of just like erased it from my
eye and i was like this is so dumb i
don't even want to like pertain to
memory
i i just i just kind of i always often
remember it you know sometimes you just
get flashbacks you wake up at night
sweating yeah you wake up there was
vampires you wake up you're just like
whatever happened to those vampires what
did they disappear
they were built up as like the big
[ __ ] villains or something
and then they just they just went
nowhere with it yeah yeah i guess that's
the
the problem of when you're like
serializing a manga every week i wonder
how much of it like
is actually planned before and how much
of it just feels like it's falling apart
which is which is why like the more
manga i read the more i respect
something like one piece which can keep
coherency
this long you know what i mean and again
and just continually getting
more continually and just continually
getting better and better
but i mean like that's also why i really
value when
a manga just has a good ending not even
a manga but just any
me any media in anime mango or light
novels
that just has an ending that people are
satisfied with i don't ask for much
but i do ask for a satisfactory ending
to win
i've just the more i've been reading
manga my pet peeve is like where it just
starts to fall apart in the last 40 50
chapters yeah that's been really that's
been happening a lot nothing nothing
ruins i feel like an experience of going
through this entire long journey with
these characters that you fall in love
with in this world that is interesting
to come to like olympic ending you know
what i mean like
they're they're like i i swear to god i
can count the amount of
like satisfying endings on like my hands
in in that i've read in manga right
because there is like most of the manga
that i love
are still ongoing like classics like
berserk
vagabonds finland saga for example
and then there are like other things
like slam dunk where you just feel
you know it just kind of kind of just
ended you know what i mean it had its
you know well come on
you can't say that that final chapter of
slam dunk
don't spoil it for me i want to read it
okay well essentially like i'm not going
to tell you how the story goes because
there's a lot to unpack but basically
like
slam dunk i've really liked the final
chapter of slam dunk because it was kind
of like
experimental almost because almost
another dimension
no no we're the basketball slam dunk no
because uh what what really made that
like what final chapter famous was the
fact that almost the entirety of the
final chapter has no dialogue yeah
that's cool and it's just like like
basically he was just like
let me just show you the story rather
than telling you the story i i don't
have the problem with the final chapter
uh i
i just felt like like without the
wrap-up
they could have gone further with the
entire story and i feel like he just
kind of ran out of ideas and just kind
of just ended it you know what i mean
but
it's not that it wasn't a great final
chapter it was just that i i wanted to
spend more time with these characters no
i feel like there could have been
room to spend more time that was me with
a go
so if we're talking about if we're
talking about absolute cockhold endings
like
karen ago is a show no no no not a go
manga it's it's yeah
yeah black and white isn't this one
where the this is when the ghost teaches
him yeah
the one where the ghost just doesn't end
well uh it
it just ends oh okay just ends it ends
in like a really controversial way
where people were kind of just like wow
there must have been some like strings
behind the scenes that were kind of just
like
you're going to end it this way whether
you like it or not yeah because it's
very very unsatisfactory yeah nobody was
happy are there any good endings that
you can think of of the top of your head
aside from a yes me pinpoint because i
know you're gonna i know you're about to
mention how you ask me
that's the first thing i think of when i
think of the most like
genius ending it's oil some pinpoint i
haven't read like
many manga compared to joey but i don't
know i'm i'm happy enough if it just
doesn't
completely [ __ ] itself near the end yeah
i honestly is that how is that how it is
to be like a fan
no like where you just like as long as
it doesn't completely [ __ ] everything up
even if it's like even if it's like
average i'm still satisfied yeah yeah
exactly because like i just recently
finished watching uh reading b stars
because the last volume came out like a
week ago yeah not the strongest ending
in my opinion but it wasn't a complete
[ __ ] show of an ending so i was like you
know what
i'm satisfied like okay could have been
better but it could have been a lot
worse as well
so is the ending of a manga that
important
qv source music unless
i feel like if an ending of a manga or
even an anime is good that can bring it
up from like uh
from like a decent show to like a
[ __ ] masterpiece
because i mean i mean the biggest
example i can think of is the
[ __ ] that was code gear season 2
yeah and yeah somehow the like i will
never forget it because of how
great the ending was same with something
like cowboy bebop for example as well
i think the ending matters more in anime
than it does in manga
what do you think is the difference i
don't know i think the way that you
length length in the way that you
experience it i remember
vastly the best bits for manga
more than i do like i said when i look
back on manga i remember it's like an
amalgamation
of like the whole experience reading it
yeah as opposed to episodes and like
scenes
right and also um yeah so i just find
that
when i finish a manga i'd rarely ever
think about the ending of any of them i
just think about my favorite moments
i'm the complete opposite you think
about the ending i think with manga i
think more about like certain scenes
whereas with anime i think about it kind
of in as a whole yeah yeah and i think
maybe it's because
i binge anime so i kind of experienced
the anime
all at once whereas with manga a lot of
it because it's you know rather long
for me a couple of episodes that's right
i binge both so
i guess ending is always important to me
yeah um especially
if i've i felt like i've spent like a
lot of time with these characters
like like it doesn't have to be a it
doesn't have to be like an amazing
ending but what i want is a satisfying
ending but
if there's an ending that is actually
amazing and
sticks with me then i'll always remember
that manga that's true
because i read all of vinlan saga which
is amazing yeah up to the point where it
was out like a few months ago yeah
and if i never read it again i'd
probably be happy knowing that i had a
good story
up to where it or before i got to which
sounds weird because it like literally
was in the middle of like a fight
yeah like you know what i've read a lot
i've read
so much of this that i'm actually
satisfied like yeah
if if i just stop reading this manga
i'll be okay yeah like i'm fine but
but i guess that's where the
double-edged sword is right is that the
longer the manga goes for
the more greater of an ending you expect
i think almost i guess
sometimes or sometimes you just because
sometimes you are
you've read a mark for so long that you
kind of just want it to end
you can get you kind of just because
that was me with naruto
so many that would be naruto that was me
with bleach
you know what i mean where they they got
to a point when i was just like i am
reading this
purely because i've invested so much
time in it yes
it's the league problem right you're
just like i've invested so much time
with this
yeah that i just need to i just need to
play it out like what
what would you say is the cap then you
just know it's like a feeling right like
when i was reading i
shield like when i got like chapter like
250 i'm like all right let's wrap it up
but it had like another 100 left right i
was like like this felt like it went on
long enough like it felt like they were
adding too many things
like yeah and a lot of mangrove had that
where like what was once
a gigantic threat earlier on yeah even
though they haven't changed much in
power
will suddenly be like they dispatch it
in like once one hit right
there's so many stuff like that where
it's like so this really cool [ __ ]
enemy you introduced you start just
one-shotting later on it's like what's
the point of this like you're just
completely ruining all the stakes over
and over again i hate it
also some reason man some [ __ ] action
scenes are like
non-impossible to figure out what the
[ __ ] is going on in manga like i'm i'm
looking at these panels and the [ __ ]
going on and i'm like
i i would need to like get my [ __ ]
pen and draw along
to like try and figure out what the
actual choreography is
like like bird's eye view kind of like
i would have more chance having like a
battlefield view and you'd showing me
like
like little [ __ ] statues movies right
jojo fans trying to figure out
king crimson yeah before the anime yeah
that was literally me i was like what's
going on
so many at manga i'm like i will sit
there for a good like 30 seconds staring
at this like
yeah i have no i have to [ __ ] idea
that's the problem i had with like
earlier on
because i'm reading and i'm like these
stand powers are getting so
[ __ ] weird that i'm looking at
something and i'm like
i guess this stand is doing its power
but i don't know what the [ __ ]
it's doing which which is odd because
then an action in manga i
start like not really care about because
half the time you can barely [ __ ]
tell what's actually happening
and you're just like putting the dots i
don't know there's something about
watching the fight unfold yeah like the
way it was meant to in like a timed way
with music and noise
so much more satisfying i i don't know
because i feel like that is the problem
with
a lot of anime fights period right is
that they don't
actually feel like fights they feel like
just
they feel like impacts intermittently
uh with with dialogue basically you know
what i mean yeah because like no one
know it
you see some anime fights and you think
no one actually fights like this
you know what i mean no one throws a
punch says a sentence
and throws a punch back you know what i
mean that that's not how fights work
which is literally every bucky fight
ever
exactly right what's a fight without a
dialogue come on
because like that's why for example the
fights in god of high school
really stood out to me because they
actually felt like a martial arts fight
you know what i mean
they say what you want about the story
or the whatever but the way the fights
were directed and framed and
just choreographed they felt like actual
fight
they felt like it felt like a jackie
chan fight right yeah yeah exactly
and i'm because that's what that's what
immediately stood out to me about
that direction and that animation was
that you know sometimes you get like the
narrative episode where you have like
you have like the basic normal narrative
fights and then you have like this one
episode
that is just like this the studio
putting all their budget and their a
team
on one [ __ ] fight and then that you
that that is the fight that people
remember you know what i mean
but most anime fights are just they're i
mean they they are literally just
animated manga panels and you can't tell
what's going on in the manga panel with
action
most of the time so that's really what
sets the good fights from the bad fight
sometimes you need that dialogue right
to help build it up
it's like a it's like a good pawn right
sometimes you need the story to make the
[ __ ] worthwhile
of course but you know i think there's
like a limit to how much dialogue you
know
like you know that's one thing i didn't
like about like a lot of naruto fights
is the fact that it's like i don't need
a [ __ ]
flashback in the middle of a pilot i
don't need that
yeah i like when they're like
internalizing their thoughts on the
battle
that's more interesting to me than yeah
i'm [ __ ] like ah you're strong and
it's like
obviously that's why you're [ __ ]
fighting each other not gonna lie my my
least favorite
like anime fight trope is like the the
guy in the sidelines explaining
everything while it's happening to be
fair that that's either hit or miss
yeah because the only like one of the
only sp
like like it's it's either speed wagon
or it's [ __ ] basically
pretty much it's like it's like i don't
know how this person is
able to like explain every [ __ ] like
physics movement
as this guy is doing a [ __ ] one-inch
punch right it's like it's like
what is the time frame how is that
happening and then there's like bucky
which is just like you you have an
esports commentator
just like explaining every detail and
technique and the [ __ ] backstory
i love that man it's [ __ ] great i
love it that's the thing right it's like
if it's like jojo obaki where it's it's
it's gotten to the point where it's so
unrealistic that it just becomes
ridiculous
exactly i like that exactly but i hate
it when they try and make it as if it's
happening in real time
and it's like don't kid yourself guys
like there's no like you'd have to be
[ __ ]
like rap god in order to like commentate
over that [ __ ] quickly as it's
happening
yes sometimes you see you just hear a
piece of dialogue in the time it takes
us for like one punch to get thrown yeah
and like a punch is just like a [ __ ]
millisecond right and they have this
five minute dialogue in the middle of
their head
in between this punch getting thrown
it's like a multi-page like
exchange right it's like where's the
punch where's the impact
yeah you're caught sorry i'm just like
is time dilation just a thing when the
anime characters get punched or
something
like einstein's rolling in his grave
right now when whenever a punch gets
thrown man
yeah and also how many [ __ ] manga is
there where like someone gets [ __ ]
stabbed and then like they're like but
you fell in my trap and it's like
how many how many times have you
practiced this where you just been like
stabbed or punched and this was like
part of your plan like
this is just like two it happens so
[ __ ] often or like sometimes they'll
get like a fatal wound
and they'll immediately like heal it and
it's like what yeah but then again right
it's like
that that kind of goes back into the
whole thing of like how ridiculous it
bucky does that so [ __ ] often where
it's like you should be dead
after one punch but you've somehow
managed to survive like 10 punches
a stab wound and like three gunshots and
you're still able to like form a
dialogue
well i feel like bucky is just what like
one side of the extreme way it's so
extreme that you can't take it seriously
anymore
i mean i mean a lot of anime fights on
like anime troops like
anime is just normalized getting punched
and coughing up blood
whereas in real life you're internally
hemorrhaging
you're probably gonna die if you
internally hemorrhage let's be honest
if you cough up blood bro
it's not gonna be good if you smash your
head through a concrete wall which is
apparently
normal in anime then you've got a
[ __ ] concussion you know
or or just a splattered head like you'll
have no head
probably exactly i want a realistic like
toe stabbing scene in anime that's what
i want that's what i want to experience
what i mean could have done it yeah yeah
probably
toe stubbing is like the the closest i
get to a real life anime scene right
i want someone to just animate someone's
stubbing their toe and then it's just
like immediate like a jojo's like
like cough up blood they're like
like probably did something because like
in real life i don't know what it is
about stubbing your toe like you stub
your toe
and it's one of the few injuries you get
where you do it and you know the pain is
coming
but for some reason there is a pain
delay between you
stubbing your toe and the immense pain
you're about to feel
like if there was a time for a real life
anime flashback
it's it's in that delay it's in that
pain delay man if now if you're an anime
character you would realize
you can synchronize your energy to
counter the below incoming
that's right come on come on come on you
can stop the nervous system from
delivering it to your brain exactly
yeah that's that's the closest you get
to a [ __ ] anime injury or whatever
i i wonder do you guys want to talk
about attack on titan because
twitter's funny right now twitter is
funny
i mean what is there to talk about like
i didn't realize
how much for [ __ ] clown fiesta
twitter is about attack on titan how
how has how have people turned this into
a thing to like dislike
i don't understand like i don't like i i
knew there was something wrong when i
woke up in the morning and went on to
twitter
like thank you yes
[ __ ] are these clowns doing now it's
it's like every time
every time attack on titan airs that you
go on twitter and something about attack
on titan is trending yeah so
the time of recording is episode six
yeah it came out
yeah yeah yeah and basically the most
recent thing that happened
was what was it people people on twitter
were just attacking the staff members
they were what's wrong with like i think
i think what i've read was
some people were just harassing the
director for one of the music choices
that was that was made
um in one of the big scenes and it got
so bad that he had to deactivate his
twitter
he did yeah yeah and a bunch of
animators as well getting harassed i'm
literally watching this thing like this
is [ __ ] amazing
why are people getting angry like is
there like what was wrong with the song
like who the [ __ ] no maybe
it's i i like i'm [ __ ] losing words
because
it's so [ __ ] so stupid and dumb if
you do that
you don't deserve anime i'm just saying
right now like you just you just don't
deserve you ain't a real animal
you're not a real anime fan if you don't
what blows my mind is that like
at the end of the day a lot of these
people right we're just we're just anime
fans why
on earth do you think you have the right
to that just go to like the director or
whatever
yeah right i [ __ ] hate the [ __ ]
audacity to be like you try and make an
anime
let's see how you if you can make a
[ __ ] good like you know what i want
to do is like i just want to like
kind of because i think one of the
things i saw yesterday was people were
complaining about
uh one of the titans being like really
bad cgi
i'm watching this thing right and the
cgi is honestly like barely noticeable
yeah it's
really like not even remotely like yeah
i just want to like go up to all those
people complaining about the cgi and
like link them to any scene from like
berserk 2016. yeah like
this is what basically these are the
same people who will [ __ ] take the
clip right
and then run it through [ __ ] sony
vegas call it 4k and re-upload it
and be like this is a 4k fight scene
guys that's my
least favorite thing like it's it's
absolutely absurd
like 60 fps for game fight scene which
is like the legends
baby the description is like i fixed
this fight
i made it better dumbest [ __ ] thing
you cannot don't do that
i i yeah i mean i i was because i
tweeted out saying something like
[ __ ] ass attack on titan b
really do be carrying 20 21. obviously
not being 100 serious about that i'm not
literally sitting there being like my
2021
would be ruined if attack on titan
wasn't error like like there's some
my god the arguments that [ __ ] arose
in those cards
i i made like i made like an attack on
titan tweet immediately muted it
i was just like i i've done this enough
times before to know
that saying anything about attack on
titan whether positive or negative
you just set up you just set off a
minefield yeah you know what i mean it's
like i
i you know i tweeted it i came back four
hours later and then
you know as i'm you know because you've
refreshed your twitter you see the most
recent reply
and it was something about like japanese
wailing laws that they were arguing
about and then i clicked on it excuse me
so i i click on this thing and it goes
up like
50 replies back and forth these two
people going at it
because one of them said that like
re-zero season two was going to be
better and they somehow devolved into
like
an attack on japan and i was like what
the [ __ ] is
this people have like anything else to
do i just i just don't understand
how people can be angry about like a
great thing
like even if there's cgi in it that is
badly noticeable
what's wrong it's getting adapted and it
looks good we're getting what we want i
don't understand
why people are being so pathetic i feel
like this is coming from
the perspective of a lot of let's say
more like
entitled margaritas right because you
can be disappointed in some ways of an
anime adaptation because
there are sometimes when you read a
manga and you have an imagination about
how this manga is going to play out if
it was animated and
with something like attack on titan
where the bar by studio wit
was set so [ __ ] high right
that you go to mapper which i still
think mapper is doing
[ __ ] fantastic job we've had bangers
sorry we've had [ __ ] bangers
absolutely
and what i will say is like it's like
the tiniest of nitpicks right where
i would say that it's gone from like a
10 hour 10
adaptation to like a 9 out 10 adaptation
that's that's that's the thing right
it's it's it's a very slight step down
from which it's not bad by any step
it's just a very slight step down it's
like like the people are taking that as
if it went from like a ten to a one
yeah yeah exactly right and the thing is
it's a nine out of ten adaptation
for 10 hour 10 material you're still
getting a [ __ ] banger so i
i don't [ __ ] get it it's not seven
deadly sins season three so i don't i
really do not understand the problem
here
and like you know these are the the
people who uh uh getting this nitpicky
on twitter and those manga readers
are just the exact same kind of people
who are just like when they're kids born
if their kid [ __ ] up anything they're
like wow it's ruined it's fine yeah
i i you know all my expectations should
have [ __ ] you know i mean it's really
what can i say
what are they just like this isn't like
what was in their mind
they're basing it off their own life if
if the child [ __ ] up they're like well
[ __ ] you didn't stick
like looking at the ultrasound they're
seeing the baby born it's like well
that's not that's not
that's not a good adaptation isn't it
you tell me it's not going to be six
foot
honestly just put it exactly get rid of
the same come on
complete on a tangent that's how i
completely feel about gender of your
parties
i don't i don't understand the point of
gender reveal
i've seen so many [ __ ] like absurd
gender about
gender reveal party clips on like tick
tock and stuff like that where i'm just
like
this is just hilarious now did you see
the one where it's like
[ __ ] what was it it was like there was
like a a balloon
like a giant [ __ ] balloon like you
know maybe like this this is the
weirdest [ __ ] tangent we've ever done
no because because one of what i was
what i was thinking was like no i was
just gonna say like there's just like a
giant like six
seven foot balloon that this guy carries
yeah and he's just like all right i'm
gonna pop it
and it just explodes into this like
colored like powder that just
completely fills up the backyard no
because what i'm thinking right is okay
the point of gender reveal party is
to reveal the gender of the baby right
right and celebrate that
but like at which point do you does like
a gender get revealed and the father's
just like
oh it's it's a girl oh karen
karen get the get the go get the coat
hanger we're doing it again like
what what kind of what kind of reaction
do you expect
the father and the mother to have you
know what i mean like what human
like most normal people will be like
whether it's a guy or a girl
the reaction's gonna be the same you're
gonna have a kid i just think that we
celebrate too many things
you know i think we have enough things
to celebrate the hardest is to just say
it's a boy
like how hard is it it's like having the
kid's birthday like not enough
like we don't just like i don't i like
to me i legitimately don't understand
like
we have so many things to celebrate it's
[ __ ] who's planning all this [ __ ]
like who has this much free time
honestly i
i barely can like get christmas plans
together
like who who has this is it the woman
she's pregnant shouldn't she be focused
on that like i don't
i don't get it i wonder if there's like
self-fulfilling prophecy of like some
people working in retail in america when
a person comes in being like give me all
of your blue dye
i need as much blue dye as possible and
they're like [ __ ] all right another one
of these all right
but yeah back to attack on titan
that was a weird transition
bottom line stop [ __ ] complaining
about attack on time it's good
i just feel like i just feel like it's
like because you know we've got
i think it's about edge people out there
who are just like i don't want to admit
that attack with titan is the best thing
right now yeah i'm i don't want to give
it more clout than it deserves
and you know you see these [ __ ] god
awful takes on twitter being like yeah
it was boring dropped it right away
it's like who cares just let the people
who are enjoying it [ __ ] enjoy it
yeah
it's good stop [ __ ] on that's the
thing it's like you can have you can
have an opinion
about it right like if you get [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] whatever don't [ __ ] harass the
animators over it yeah it's the same
thing with like when game of thrones is
like around right people
like you know people just wanted to be
that person who's like yeah i don't like
game of thrones
uh yeah whatever are you happy about it
[ __ ] that's lame bro i'm not
i'm not excited about it i'm not excited
about anything bro except for gender
reveal party
yeah the only thing i get excited for is
my baby's gender
you know what i mean like i don't know
yeah and for some reason
you know i mean it does happen in other
genres as well
but for some reason who are these i
don't even know the [ __ ] ants of
these craters that twitter how are they
finding this [ __ ] why
and why are they finding this [ __ ] just
a [ __ ] act though but tell them it's
[ __ ]
right as if like one of the anime is
going to be like oh thanks for your
feedback we'll change it to yeah like
they go
they go to their annual meeting like yo
guys you're seeing this people people
don't like it what the [ __ ]
yeah so like uh mikasa276 on twitter
said that
we should just completely change the
episode it just changed studios
yeah like what director's gonna be like
rfm i got you i mean it kind of sucks
that
you know in the time where the japanese
industry and japanese staff members are
starting to you know we want them to
open up yeah to open up more to the
international community
this is the [ __ ] they have to deal with
for some of like the biggest profile
i kind of want to just go up and be like
don't open up it's not worth it
don't go don't go to school i do think
you know there's a good amount of people
who are probably selling hate who
probably don't want it to open up right
so i think
it it's you know it's the same thing
with like the idol and like kind of
almost like the whole life fan base a
little bit where they're like we don't
want our
our people to interact outside ruin them
we don't want the normies
we don't want we don't yeah we don't
want like the american corporations
getting their fingers in our japanese
like anime you know i mean there's a lot
of people who are like that right as
as if they're japanese themselves yeah i
mean a lot of the time it does come from
a place of you know
not in japanese yeah yeah yeah we like
our
country i get it if they were japanese
yeah yeah but most if not all
it's like in your video when you did the
uh the anime studio tour
yeah and like the guy who was the
director of the studio was like oh we
have foreign fans
yeah and like he like genuinely yeah so
the ceo of cloverworks
genuinely didn't know that they had i
mean a lot of people don't know that
they have to blame them if he goes on
twitter [ __ ] yeah people are gonna
tell him to kill himself what
like i would be like no they don't exist
no they don't they don't
honestly like like it's embarrassing i'm
just saying you do to make you feel
better
i mean i suppose if you think about it
it's the same way if it's the same
mentality of like for example if you
found out that trash tate has
or something had japanese fans you know
what i mean it's just like oh there's
people in japan who watch us
we have russian dub what
what's foreign on here get emails every
week be like you guys know you have like
a russian dog
yeah we know what we've spoke about yeah
we get it would you say that attack on
titan is carrying your 2021
so far yeah dude every episode i'm
getting [ __ ] hyped for people should
just you know be appreciative of the
fact that we're even [ __ ] getting
attack on time right like
in the midst of a [ __ ] pandemic yeah
i mean the fact is that attack on titan
it's it could be carrying any year
because i don't think that anything
can live up to what attack on titan
season four is giving us right now and
i say this in the midst of what i would
one of the strongest seasons we've ever
had
i would argue that this is the front
this is a
contender for one of the strongest
seasons
in the history of anime yeah that is a
big statement
but like it's so
stacked in every single genre
and every single kind of ev every single
category you can think of that
i can't think of a single person who
can't find at least two or three shows
that they'll be watching this season
and then on top of that you have the
classic being made that is attack one
time
why would you you know if i was an anime
studio and i found out when attacking
titan was airing i'd be like you know
what just [ __ ] hold on
just like don't don't let's wait like
on youtube you know if you upload a
video when like shane dawson dropped a
documentary it was like just don't just
don't like
you you're like family movie companies
being like wait avengers and cinnamons
right now
at least at the same
i would have been like just hold off
because attack on titan's gonna
carry like even if i only get to watch
it once a week it's gonna be in my mind
the whole week
so like just hold off and give me a
banger next season but now they all
everyone's like let's all come out right
now let's let's all have all our bangers
right now in this one season because
like the amount of like
we've had a few seasons previously with
some season twos here and there yeah but
it seems like
every season two or like sequel this
season
is a [ __ ] banger yeah because like
his b stars is airing right now right
okay so i do not know any no one is
talking about it yeah because attack on
titan is the only thing anyone can get
to shoot that's right
now okay okay so we got b stars too
which is going to be amazing we've got
promised net we got promised neverland
we're sure
no one is talking about yes neville and
came out it was
massive yeah it was all anyone wanted to
talk about yeah um
we got log horizon 3 quince2 uh
quintessential quintuplets too
we got um dr stone too yeah
um huh i sleep i sleep attack on titan
season two
yeah basically i mean like it's how can
you not man like every episode is just
like a [ __ ] like
roller coaster yeah and like for a lot
of people we've been
on this for like five plus years this
year yeah it's a journey right
it's it's and it's and it's one of the
few ones where
it feels like it's run its actually
natural
actually coming to an end you know what
i mean and you know i i
i said in a tweet that i feel like this
is a we're watching a classic being made
and i i have no doubts that
if like even if he doesn't like
completely slam dunk the ending even if
it's just an
okay satisfying ending it's gonna go
down as long as it's not like the
crummiest [ __ ] ending imagine yeah
yeah
wait for it multiverse i'm predicting
multiple yeah
which i would like to think is not going
to happen please forgot
two is there in the season oh yeah yeah
again you just can't complain
yeah no one's talking about anything and
i'm just like there's so many [ __ ]
bangers this season
and like attack on titan is just taking
over
like i'm sure because i remember i was
watching the last season of breaking
badass it was airing
week by week i'm sure i watched other tv
shows during that time
i cannot tell you what i watched other
than than [ __ ] breaking bad
like it was like the highlight right
like it's what it takes up your your
space and your hype
for like well for what's good it's going
to be 26 episodes i think right on titan
no it's gonna be 14. it's 14. yeah so
right now from what i've heard like
this this is this is me going off of
what i've got speculation warning
manga manga readers so it's going to be
14 episodes i think
14 or 15 which doesn't take it up to the
end of the manga because the end of the
manga
ends in april or something yeah i heard
that april may i can't remember but it's
confirmed that the manga is going to be
ending
this late spring summer kind of time i
thought they were trying to do like a
dual ending where it was going to be
they both were like ending at the same
time i thought oh like an anime
originally
so no no like it was gonna they he was
probably gonna i thought he meant
maybe he was gonna like tell them the
studio the ending no so
what so with the confirmed amount of
episodes
that that's out so far what people are
thinking is gonna happen is either we're
gonna get a season four part two
[ __ ] or we are going to get a movie oh
i would i'm speculating it's gonna be a
movie
we can do that with the last attack on
titan thing just saying
honestly like if i'm have to speed run
the hunger real quick
i'll be like i'm going down like joey
joe what are you saying
there's a [ __ ] type it out joey
please live translate for me come on
yeah because i'll hire a professional
like you know the ones with the
governments when they go to the like
meetings i'll hire him to get in the
seat behind me in the theater
whispering all i'm gonna say is like
personal reasons i wish
i hope it's gonna be a movie just so i
could be the first one to make a video
on it
i'll go oh i'm gonna go to the midnight
screening and i'm gonna make a video and
be like yeah guys
it was epic that time where uh i i i'm
i would not do that i'm kidding i'm
joking i would not ruin
possibly one of the greatest anime to go
down in history
by just what youtube clickbait i feel
like so hey guys i think i know what
happened
i watched it all three times i think i
got the gist of what's going on that was
me with maiden abyss
what the [ __ ] is the movie called
legitimate okay
yeah we watched the made in abyss movie
with like obviously there's no subtitles
right yeah
like i'm pretty sure i understood what
happened
i'm pretty happy i'm pretty sure i got
it i i got the gist it was like
plot plot questionable child porn plot
and i was just like oh kevin you did you
did uh you did a good job cause kevin
was sitting right next to us
look damn this song's good man it's like
going to haul questionable childhood
music good yeah basically but
uh yeah like i everyone said the maiden
abyss movie was amazing and i'm just
like yeah
good time i still haven't seen it
honestly it's fine
well i mean i'm not gonna take your word
for it because
as a man who understood half of what was
being said it was fine
this episode of trash taste is sponsored
by g fuel what flavor you drinking
garlic i am drinking star starfruit
flavor right now i'm drinking pink
lemonade wow and i'm drinking
faze berry if you want your own g fuel
you can use code trash taste to get 30
off g fuel thanks g fuel links in the
description back to the episode
can we talk about the real masterpiece
airing the season though
oh and joey joey knows what i'm talking
about it was really funny because i was
i was just about to bring it up
so so forget forget this attack on titan
slander
or like whatever we're going to call the
classic yeah the real classic that's
coming out this season
is an anime called xx um so i'm uh
i'm a complete noob now i have seen
clips of it but can you please explain
to me what exam is in its
totalness it is hilarious it is
an experience i will say that so
i think we have literally got the mass
effect andromeda
releases of anime if you know what i
mean cyberpunk
finish so this is
i i didn't know anime could have bugs
and glitches that's all i'm going to say
so it is a crunchyroll original
right and you know that crunchyroll are
proud of this because i have not seen
a single piece of promotional work about
this
i saw the trailer on youtube and i
thought it was a
joke and the show looks
worse than that no it looks it looks
worse yeah i i hate to say to you but
the trailer is probably the best part
about the show yeah the trailer isn't
the trailer the trailer is the anime
probably makes it good doesn't it but
it's so bad
i was crying in laughter the first
episode it
is like i think the third lowest anime
on mal
right now after one episode after one
episode but you're laughing so
yeah i mean it's it's uh that's that's
what it's a masterpiece
of trash basically it's it's [ __ ] no
like it's like the first time i watched
like ghazi's wing right yeah or like you
know helter-skev and i was like a skill
to heaven i was like this is
i'm watching a masterpiece but on the
opposite end so to explain exam it is a
control original
anime um that is made by a completely
new studio
by a team who's never worked in anime
before american
no japanese japanese team but uh they've
never worked in anime before and
it shows it shows it shows that they've
never worked in anime
before and um it is a 3d anime
that looks like it was made by a
five-year-old who just
learned blender like yesterday
it makes ruby look like it makes ruby
season one look like an absolute master
i was gonna watch it but i just wanted
to get like drunk enough yeah just to
like fully enjoy it oh it makes berserk
2016 look like akira you know what i
mean yeah
it's pretty bad it is and what's worse
is that like i posted the clip of it on
twitter but like there's a scene
right near the beginning where the main
character is 3d
but his brother is in 2d
so you have this truly awful
[ __ ] cg like blocky minecraft
character standing next to this
2d anime character and he's literally
the same scene in the same
shot and he literally looks he literally
looks green screened on
you know what i mean it looks like
someone just learned it looked like
someone just had learned this
the he's like he's like yo you heard of
this thing called a chroma key
exactly
you can see it on screen right now oh my
god
oh my god that's awful it's like in the
same space
you know what that is that's like that
looks like if you told me
that was uh what's that uh what's that
game where everyone can have their own
avatars in the game it looks like
they're like
second life whatever it's called yeah it
looks like if like you know how like
someone people have their own servers
name like 2d things and they have like
the 3d models
that's what it looks like you know what
that looks like that looks like someone
took like a regular anime and made like
an mmd editor of it
yeah i mean see it i can see it because
it is like that quality actually mmd is
a better industry
and then like if that wasn't already bad
there was just like
some of the fight choreography is just
hilarious like this is one fight scene i
think like it's like the last fight
scene of the first episode where there
was just
no music it's like they forgot to put in
the music it's just like
like that but there's no music
whatsoever so it's just i was watching
it and i was just like
is there something wrong with my
headphones like why is there no music
playing
i remember like in in the last part they
run out or something and it's literally
a guy who looks like
actually it's literally looks like the
characters are like being animated with
a stick or something like that
there's literally no like they're not
moving their limbs or something they're
just like
rocking from side to side so we're
talking that like
that like queen bee would put them to
shame oh i wish this was animated by
queen oh dude
it makes queen bee look like studio
weird it's it's [ __ ] horrible yeah
but it's also just a really fun time
like i had a lot of fun watching the
first episode yeah
always see what i mean i want to get
some drinks and just enjoy it you know
oh we need to it's so funny
this would be like even better if it had
like kind of like a ghost stories dub
so someone needs to dub exxon
crunchyroll
please don't to be ashamed of exile
you're sitting on a golden duck here
just just market it correctly and people
will meme the [ __ ] out give us the
rights to dublin
we'll [ __ ] dub it we'll [ __ ] make
an amazing double fit you know what i
mean
can't wait to direct those sessions
and like the opening song as well
just what is that the one that sounds
like some some 41. yeah it sounds
something yeah it sounds like a
it sounds like a sun 41 cover yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think i heard that was the
one that used for the trailer right yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that is just the anime yeah just sent me
it was like what the [ __ ] is this it's
like some 2002
[ __ ] yeah what the [ __ ] what is this god
damn
it's like it's like a high school band
that listened to too much green day
you know what i mean
it does sound like a cover band doesn't
it oh my god
that is perfect but yeah why is no one
talking about that i don't know
you you have attack on titan season four
but who gives a [ __ ] about it
who greenlit that like no sorry like who
who let that through like
quality assurance like who let that
throw what quality
like there's normally people who are
like yeah this is good to go who
who deadass watched that first episode
was like yeah it's good
i wonder though if someone at like the
production team was like
i feel like we're forgetting something
qa oh [ __ ]
you know how sometimes when like people
like make shows but it's just one big
like tax fraud scheme
yeah what if it's like i shouldn't say
that i could get in trouble actually
yeah
it's definitely just just a joke that's
a joke that's a joke
you know just saying my god but like
i wonder what the people working on it
think of this you know anime because you
know
sometimes sometimes you work on a
project that you're
not proud of you know you know what i
mean because
people want to get at paid end of the
day
they're like i mean i gotta just keep
turning up and doing what they ask right
that's what i imagine is happening i
don't know
i just like to imagine that like the
animes came back to like the producer
and was like
yeah the the the models look great um so
like put some shading on it put you know
a little more animation on the producers
like so it's coming out tomorrow
i just i just want to know because you
know and like in any like anime
production or any big project production
you know you have this you have this
screening night
right where you you as a group as the
team you get
to watch the final product before it
airs i just want to hear the silence in
that room
when the credits roll and you just you
just what
can you say here's the thing psych in
japan
that it's always silent regardless
that's why see in america
and the west we have clapping right i
just like to think that the entire like
screening room is just like silently
nodding their head
like hell yeah everyone knows every
japanese man just waiting for the
izakaya anyway yeah
come on i just want a beer man they're
gonna get a free meal at the end of the
screening and free drinks so it doesn't
matter like that they're turning up to
the screen i turn up to the screening if
i get free meal at the end of it
listen man like as someone who's like
you know done a documentary in an anime
studio i i completely see
wow wow look at that flesh as someone
it's hard i get it it's hard but
also come on
it's hard but come on man it's hard you
know we're not we're not blaming
the probably overworked staff not at all
i'm not blaming anyone for it if
anything i'd like to thank them for
giving us some like quality
entertainment honestly it is
honestly quality entertainment i i watch
episode two and it is
also a banger oh i still need to just
coming out with that thing
man exam episode 2 is what i'm looking
forward to
are you guys watching anything else this
season or are you guys waiting to see
what gets hype
and what gets i talked about i want to
watch uh
what the [ __ ] called one drag priority
that is
one direct priority yeah weirdest
[ __ ] title but i watched the trailer
over because i heard so many people
a lot of people were asking me like hey
have you seen the first episode this i
was like
that doesn't even sound like a real
anime one direction
wait one direct party that sounds made
up yeah but then i checked out the
trailer i was like actually this kind of
looks fire
yeah it's it's too early to tell how
it's going to go
because i've watched the first episode
what is it about
that is it's it's one of those shows
where i'm just like i don't even know
what it's about
you know what i mean it's it's one of
those weird shirts you know
i asked people i was like what's it
about people just said just watch it it
feels like a like a ikuhara show or
something like that
like or something or something or
something like that
i'm just i'm just throwing out words
like corner just right you could be
speaking in tongues right
it gives me like a slight like tatami
galaxy vibe to it
you know like kind of just like it's
like so strange that it's hard to
describe
yeah vibe to it what i what i will say
it it feels like for ex
it feels like madoka magica directed by
ikuhara um it's
it's what the [ __ ] you guys talking
about what the [ __ ] so ikuhara is the
director that made sarah zanmai
uh penguin drum um what else does he
made
what else does he cohara made what's
that magical girl one day it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter you don't
you've not seen any of these works
right but he makes a lot of weird stuff
and it's
i i watched the first episode and it's
it's
the what i will say i can't really spoil
it because i don't even understand the
first episode
you know what i mean but it's a story
that it it presents the events of this
world
out of order right so you get
oh my god i'm i'm like wrecking my brain
to figure out how
kind of it's kind of presents its story
like uh like a boogie pop phantom kind
of thing yes
it's it's it is very reminiscent of
being so fantastic i just realized like
if you have no context of what you're
talking about it actually just sounds
like you guys are talking about
gibberish
what's the weirdest anime you've watched
connor where you just [ __ ] know
like a lot of the when people are like
dude you got to watch this animate so
it's kind of like
on the same vein of serial experiments
lane boogie pop
phantom i i feel like you just haven't
watched
you put those shows on you're like
there's no way you could enjoy this
without doing like
four tabs of acid you know what i mean
like like a lot of shows are like that
and then i mean maybe with serial
experiments lame but i i'd argue that
like something like boogie board phantom
is
more than enjoyable i don't really
concern myself i mean it's something
where you have to be in a very specific
mood to
enjoy it because it's not something you
can just put on yeah and just enjoy it
as an entertainment as like a coherent
story or something but
what i will say is out of because before
my seasonal video i watch every
the first two episodes of like every new
anime and out of
everything i watched it's the one where
i watched it
didn't know what was going on didn't
fully understand it but
i it stuck with me you know it it really
it was really the one where i kept
thinking about it after it had ended
after i'd watched everything else i was
just like
man i don't know what it is but i keep
thinking about one direct priority and i
don't know
what it is exactly about one direct
priority that makes me
latch onto it but there's something i
feel something special
no i get that i kind of i kind of got
that same feeling the first time i
watched like the first episode of like
fully [ __ ]
right it's like i don't know what the
[ __ ] is happening like this dude's
forehead little robot just came out of
it
i can give you a play-by-play of what
happens in wonder egg so
this girl there's this like short hooded
like she wears like a yellow hoodie girl
i need that um
the first scene is that a [ __ ]
circada comes along and starts talking
to her and you're like
okay whatever cool she can talk to
cicadas
and then she gets given an egg and then
she wonders what to do with this egg and
then she's sitting on the toilet and
then toilet paper starts talking to her
and she's like yo what the [ __ ] and then
the egg hatches and it turns out
that it's a girl hatches out the egg
i think i'll just watch i don't want to
spoil too much but that's
fun i mean if it you know if the weeks
go on everyone's still like yeah it's a
good show i'll watch it
i mean from what i can understand about
the first episode it deals with a lot of
themes of depression and suicide and it
seems like it's uh
it we get glimpses into our backstory
because you know
we get glimpses into is is this a dream
world
or is this imagining things or what's
kind of going on
we only get hints at everything i feel
like again it's like it's kind of like a
modern spin on fully coolly right
because like fully cool is kind of the
same whereas like
it kind of used its like absurd imagery
to present
deeper meanings yeah it's like i said
it's way too early to tell
what the show is going to be about and
how good it is but like i said out of
everything i watched
it stuck out to me the most yeah that's
what i really want to watch that's the
one i
thought about the most um but i don't
know if you would
what is the weirdest anime you've seen i
don't [ __ ] know i think you'd have to
go through my list but then
i was probably we did that we did that
last week or there's probably someone
there that i like have you ever watched
an anime or a show and you were just
like what the [ __ ] did i just watch that
made zero sense to me
like you know kind of like like not in
like the vein of like you know this was
[ __ ] kind of thing but like
just genuinely the storytelling was kind
of like on the
same lines as the ending of evangelion
or like a you know like a tick on king
creed yeah yeah i mean the first time i
watched evangelion i was like
oh what the [ __ ]
i was like oh that's how they're gonna
end it and like you know some people
love finding the deeper meaning in that
and i'm just like that was a bit [ __ ]
i'm just going to get on with my life
like it kind of i just like doesn't
really concern me
i just i wish i cared but i like i don't
and then like maybe a video about that
convenient activation yeah i think i've
like
programmed my brain to like just make my
life easier
so like when i want to just you know
stuff like that that might drive some
people mad
i'm just like monkey forget monkey move
on i just find it funny how like
considering like in a previous episode
you said like how you love to challenge
yourself every day
you definitely do not like to challenge
yourself on anime but like what what is
what is thinking about the end of end of
evangelion challenging you in any way
how is that well not necessarily in the
favor but like you know something like
you know like a fully cooling like a
tick on king where it's like
there are deeper meanings behind it wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait i
would why would this where okay here's
the thing where you watch it once and
you can't get
everything you you can't enjoy it from
just like
watching it once yeah but like why would
that challenge you though
in challenge as in like it makes you
think about
its themings more and kind of challenges
your i guess like perception of
how you like consume it i guess it's
hard to describe like
it it challenges [ __ ]
yeah right how do you explain it it's
like i've broke them
like when i watch those things where
it's like the deeper meaning everything
yeah more often than not like i
i realized that that's what they're
doing and i'm like oh okay cool and then
i'll just i'll like go on google and
i'll be like
what were they trying to say but like
don't you like because i find like some
enjoyment
in kind of watching it and trying to
figure it out myself
you know what i mean okay
it's like unraveling a puzzle by
yourself and it's
it's like playing a puzzle game right
you're given the pieces and
you know you're not told what the right
answer is but it's up to you
and it's up to you to unravel it
yourself
or it's more like it's more like you've
given a bunch of pieces
and as you're playing around with the
pieces you realize that it's a puzzle
that can you solve
this is like i love map right because
there is a problem and it is always very
clearly defined as such
right okay yeah it's it's not logical
with like yeah with stories and all that
kind of stuff
it's i don't like that i have to figure
out what this guy was thinking
about because sometimes i might get a
meaning that
is not even remotely close to what he
was thinking or the author was thinking
when they were writing the thing down
yeah and to me that bothers me
that i can just wildly get the answer
wrong and i'll never be corrected i
don't like that but you assume that that
there's a right answer yeah well it's
what if you didn't know there was a
right answer
yeah and that's the problem is that i
don't like that when there's just like
an interpretation and it's like you just
make up what you want and then it's like
right then what but
i would argue that a great story can
still entertain you
in that aspect whether it is the actual
correct answer or not yeah i mean i
don't i don't really go around like
think about it much
i guess that's the thing i just i watch
it and i i like whatever thoughts i have
when i finish i'm like
cool that's what i'm gonna leave with
and most the time i don't really care to
try and find the deeper meaning in it
and so i think again i know this is like
that's such monkey brain you can't
appreciate fine art et cetera et cetera
but
i i i'd say that's that's even more
normal
yeah at the end of the day i just don't
care like i think people
like me who like actually like trying to
find the deeper meaning i think
we're the minority yeah i think i'm the
minority here because
i talk about i the reason i value this
so much is because
there has been time where like a piece
of media has
literally affected sometimes the way i
think or the way i view life
so because i know it can have that
effect
i you know i try to search it out
whenever i can
whenever i find that there might be even
a glimpse that there might be a deeper
meaning
i love going into it i know i just like
i like everything to be efficient i like
everything to be
done you basically like everything on a
silver platter right no no not at all i
like i like it when things are very
clearly defined
the rules like this is why i like i
always like i never ever did any
artistic subjects in school right yeah i
don't like how it's or it's all like a
mess and it's totally interpretation
yeah i like how in math and physics and
life the rules
they they make sense and you can you can
like take them in and you can like
i don't know i get like you know my math
and physics were my favorite for me but
for me it's not fun
when it i'm like reading a book or
something and i'm doing this and i'm i'm
just being presented with a bunch of
nonsense that i might have to make sense
of myself
well i would argue then that if it's a
bunch of nonsense without an
interpretation then that's just a bad
story
sometimes yeah i mean sometimes you can
make your own you can make your own
thoughts up from whatever's being
presented to you
and you're just kind of like cool all
right nice
i came up with what i think happened and
then it's like all right well that's
what i think yeah because like i would
argue that like the best stories are the
ones where
you can read it like someone like you
can read it where like
you don't have to even think about the
fact that there might possibly be a
deeper meaning and it's still enjoyable
and at the same time people like me that
like to look for deeper meanings can
also enjoy it yeah like i want to get
too philosophical but
you know why why do we watch
entertainment it's to feel things
it's to make it
that's the end of be all right we watch
entertainment to make us
feel something whatever you want to feel
whether it's like [ __ ] adrenaline
sometimes you just want to feel
depressed or whatever you know it's and
watching something like for example the
ending episode of evangelion
i've i remember the first time i watched
it i [ __ ] hated it because i'm just
like
why why can i not just be given the
answer why why is the answer
not just you know being presented to me
on like a golden platter you know that's
what i wanted
and then as i grew older and i
it stuck with me and i've rewatched it
and i'm just like
oh this is this is making me feel
different things i'm sure in future
maybe
i'll change my mind on it but right now
for me uh like entertainment and media
is just like
i just want to relax and thinking is not
relaxing
i just want to get on with it because
i'm working so god damn much and i want
to do the things i want to do and to me
entertainment is purely like a gas stop
on my destination
it's like let's just stop for a moment
and have some fun nothing i'll get it no
no i mean i get that too like it's not
like every [ __ ] piece of stuff
and i watch just like mind-bending and
it's like it's like i said sometimes you
just need to be in a very specific mood
to enjoy this piece of media sometimes
i'm just like you know what yeah i want
to feel pretentious right now yeah like
i kind of want to like figure out if
this has a deeper venue which is why i i
when i speak people who talk like that
that about the media they like
i'm like you know part of me is envious
because i don't care for that
but because i think and i think a lot of
people are envious of that because i
think when you meet a lot of people
they'll claim that they can see the
finer meaning and art and yeah
and most of the time they have no
[ __ ] idea um but
you know i don't know i'm just
completely open with the fact that i'm
like
i i don't care i i don't care to care
yeah
i like what i like what i don't
understand is the other extreme where
it's people who
can't seem to enjoy media unless there
is something deeper about it
like i there are times when i just want
to watch a [ __ ] shitty esa car and
just not have to think you know what i
mean
yeah i know it's like the people who
like think that every single piece of
entertainment or media has some kind of
deeper meaning under it
you know what i mean it's like no uh
anime reviewer non non biore has no
deeper meaning it's just a [ __ ] slice
of life like just
just chill that feels like privilege the
problem it's like
my only problem is life in life is that
my media that i consume
doesn't have enough it's meaningless
it's like it's like oh my how privileged
are you to be where that's a concern you
know what i mean like
first of all that is like the biggest
first of all problem
where like you can't get enough fine art
that excites me you know what i mean
that's like literally like billionaire
probably yeah well what pisses me off
even more it's like you can have your
own interpretation of the media right
that's that's
that's very normal for everything but
what pisses me off is
when people project their own meaning
onto
this piece of media like like i remember
i remember where the tackling titan when
you know the basement thing happened and
then there were articles to be like
oh yeah this is promoting nazism and
stuff like that and i'm just like
no it's not oh god it gets it gets to a
point where there's a difference between
you know
analyzing it and you know interpreting
in your own way and just
there's even when they know the right
answer as well right it's just like no
no i don't care what the author said
this is what it actually means he just
doesn't know it again it's like no i'm
pretty sure
if the author said that this is what it
means that's what it [ __ ] means
well i mean there's plenty of cases of
where like the author loses control over
the world well i mean isn't that like
the whole thing with ava right where
like pepe the frog rip
the the death of the author right or
whatever so your boy's been up to
anything
interesting recently i mean we're
currently back in lockdown aren't we so
we haven't really been able to do much
not really japanese government's pretty
useless well i mean yeah but
i said emergency statement restaurants
please close at eight
so you can still travel and do whatever
you want but you know
it's not an enforced lockdown in japan
it's always a suggestion yeah it's just
it's a suggestion in japan people listen
yeah yeah
that was [ __ ] crazy i think like uh
where was it it was like it was
because usually after we finish
recording a podcast we go and have
dinner and stuff like that yeah and i
think we were at uh like one of the
restaurants nearby and they were playing
like news footage
and shinjuku yes there was a [ __ ]
shot of shinjuku station
zero people in front of it which is like
crazy because shinjuku station if you
guys don't know is like
literally the most busy station i think
in the world isn't it yeah yeah it is
yeah it is at least in japan no it's the
world i think
really that doesn't surprise me shinjuku
station i i die a little inside whenever
someone
whenever a friend comes to japan and i
ask where to meet and they say
yeah okay meeting at shinjuku station is
impossible but like
navigating it isn't so bad no i [ __ ]
hate it i think ikebukuro
what are you on because when you try and
get to like the other like the subway
lines
you like for some reason station
literally has like 30 exits yeah dude
has maybe like 10. like depending on
which exit you come out of
shinjuku like it tells you to go on the
other side of the station
and you would think walking in a
straight line would work no you can't
walk in a straight line in shinjuku
because you've got to pass
depending on where you're on the station
you've got to pass through like 10
different gates at least with igor
i always if if someone's just like meet
at this gate that i don't know where the
[ __ ] it is then i'll just go out of the
regular gate and i can at least walk
around the station yeah but if you try
and do that with shinjuku station you're
[ __ ]
if you ever come to japan and you're
gonna meet anyone here
and you're staying you and you're
staying near shinjuku never say you're
gonna
meet at shinjuku station it is a lie
okay
it's saying you're gonna meet at
shinjuku station it's like saying you're
gonna meet
somewhere in like times square or
something yeah it's a massive
area yeah and station doesn't do no it's
not even that it's like saying like i'll
meet you in new york
yeah that's like all right cool you just
pick a place
outside of the station and then yeah
send them the google yeah but you can do
that with
any other station would be way easy to
get out of i guess yeah because i i
remember
i i i met jeff here mother's basement at
shinjuku station and
as soon as he said it i was like oh here
we go gotta gotta find
it's basically finding where's wally
with your mates and you know with jeff
it shouldn't be hard because he's
[ __ ] massive right
yeah and he says and he i i ask him
where he is and he goes
oh i'm uh near this place i think it's
it looks like there's a big camera
nearby i'm like cool
so eight it's like yeah
like the nearest big camera and so big
camera is like this huge department
store
um it's like an electronic store
basically
um so i go to the west
shinjuku big camera right and then i
send him the message
and i'm just like okay i'm outside big
camera and he goes i don't see you and i
go
[ __ ] it was that at that point i knew
ticks off once i [ __ ] up and i and i
tell him just to send me the google map
coordinates and he's on the other side
of the [ __ ] station
he's like shinjuku west like google maps
it's so much easier
you can just literally meet at like
[ __ ] one station overview because
some of the stations [ __ ] lie
with how to get places and like
ikebukuro as well has like an east west
exit or something no dude [ __ ]
shinjuku is like has like
seven westerns it has an east west exit
yeah yeah that doesn't no no no no no
it doesn't even like shinjuku doesn't
even have an east west exit i think
shinjuku has like
an east-west exit and a new east-west
exit
that's how many exits there are in
shinjuku that they've literally run out
of directions
to name the exits i missed the train
stations in wales where it's just a
platform
right that was it that was the whole
station maybe a vending machine if you
were like
honestly like what i usually do i've
done this with a few people and it's
actually proven to be effective is that
instead of meeting in shinjuku you meet
one station down on the yamanote which
is yoyogi
because walking because walking to
yoyogi like from
shinjuku is the exact same time that it
would take to actually get out of
shinjuku station it is because walking
from one side
of the station to another depending on
where you are could take up to 15 to 20
exactly whereas like yogi
only has two exits very straightforward
nah bro what do you mean i'm doing what
you love to do best with just min maxing
myself
okay what is the optimal strategy right
google has this thing now where it tells
you which cart to get on
so it tells you which train car to get
on for the smoothest and quickest exit
and 95 of the time
it's spot on just do that i'll say a
trick question though there is no smooth
exit or shinjuku there is
there is never i have legit like i i
always feel shinjuku right and obviously
i'm always using why would you do that
because i need to and i listen to what
google my god google tells me
you know every time and it bang on it's
like go this exit go up the first
set of stairs you see every single time
it's basically right
you think someone who just come to came
to japan will like know
which direction of shinjuku and which ex
there are i don't even know which exit i
get out
of i i mean it works for me i just
listen to what the pc the mo
the pc master race tells me if the
computers tell me to go somewhere i go
where the computer is
okay connor's full of [ __ ] the first
time you come to japan don't do that no
no because you won't know how to do it
find where you want to go when you go to
the station there'll be numbers on the
floor just pick
the number what the google tells you to
go on and then do it
trust me shinjuku you all get lost
navigating the station yeah don't don't
trust the station signs because
they'll be like oh yeah if you're on the
platform be like the exits
this way don't trust the station that's
all i've got because
because when you go to shinjuku and you
follow google maps right google maps
says
take the west exit out of shinjuku and
then you go you go to
you go out your trailer you go see the
signs and there is literally
every exit but the exit that it says on
google maps
you've made right you've made the
mistake you're looking at the signs
right
the signs what is there to look at
otherwise the signs
all they do is deceive you they they
make you second guess
right don't listen to the system so full
of [ __ ] listen to what google says 100
right because thing is right you'll be
on the platform right and there'll be
like eight sets of stairs that you can
take
that'll be an hour this is like this way
this is the way to where you want to go
and sometimes it's like the most
unoptimized way to get out of the like
to
out of the station or go to the line
that you want to go right and there's a
bunch of stairs and sometimes it isn't
clear which stairs to get
it's a mess right if google tells you to
get off at a cart
go immediately to the nearest set of
stairs that you see
i guarantee it'll work and just go out
the exit that you see closest it'll
always work
google knows don't listen to the signs
they're a [ __ ] lie
done try it boys you'll see i don't know
man i
it's i think i'll just avoid getting off
of shinjuku i just i just feel like not
going through shinjuku
is just the optimal strap that's like
saying like
i'm just i want to fly out of the
country without an airport it's like
if you're gonna go to japan you're gonna
be going through shinjuku yeah but like
i'd rather meet like somewhere far away
from the actual station get me out of
this place
somewhere anywhere near the station yeah
because it's just
extra it's just extra stress you're
adding on to your commute
if you let the ai do it for you i don't
know because
it i have tried following the ai and
google maps
isn't perfect it's pretty good is this
why is this why you hate ikebukuro
more because the ais i have no [ __ ]
clue
because so that's what you hate
such a [ __ ] mess of the station the
way it's been laid out like shinjuku i
get it it makes sense no it doesn't but
the thing
is that the science makes sense yeah you
can see the signs
that when i follow a sign to an exit it
actually takes me to the [ __ ] exit
yeah
like because i like putting my trust in
my own sense of direction right
so if i'm in a place like ikebukuro i
can trust that
wherever i am i can find the right way
out i just follow the signs
i just you know follow the signs i want
the optimal not the right way
with with shinjuku i'm if you literally
have to put your trust
in an ai machine to tell you the right
direction
then it is just a poorly planned system
exactly you know
i mean hey it works though i get where i
need to get to
there's no problem well we'll say that
this is such a
i wonder people watching this you've
never been to japan like what the [ __ ]
is this problem
yeah yeah if you've never been to japan
don't listen to connor yeah
listen anywhere outside of shinjuku
trunks listen to the white guy
yeah would you trust the white guy
listen listen to me the white guy
trust me i find life hacks where they
don't exist
yeah i mean with lockdown there's not so
much new i can be doing
so recently i had this um had a
woke up one day and i was just like i
should get back into fake go
no no i saw your thing about that i was
just like no no no
no it's like watching it's like watching
your friends start a new drug you know
what i mean it's like
no please stop it's just seeing your
mate like just relapsing just like no
no we were past this you were 10 weeks
sober man
come on i mean i'm kind of the same way
like i uh
i did something that i haven't done in
literal years which is
by an arrogant like a japanese okay like
a brand new
like okay just came out arrogant so
because
okay so i was in akihabara a while back
um doing some shopping for a video
and uh and i was walking past like melon
books which is like you know where they
sell a lot of like doujins and stuff
and out the front okay so basically so
out the front they have like a bunch of
signs for like new games that come out
right and every now and then they'll
also show some signs for like error gaze
right because yeah that's where they
sell it
and there was one where i was just like
that actually looks really cool like i
didn't actually know it was an arrogant
i thought it was like
a standard jrpg or whatever yeah but i
was like that actually kind of looks
cool so i looked it up
found out it's an error game by alice
soft and i was like
wow alisoff actually just [ __ ] like
click
baited me into thinking that this was
like a legitimate jrpg when it's just a
[ __ ] arrogant with jrpg elements in
it
so i was like all right you know what
i'll bite
i'll bite it's lockdown i can't really
go out anywhere yeah and i haven't
[ __ ] bought and played an error game
so many years
yeah [ __ ] it i'll do it played it and uh
that's kind of all i've been doing for
the past three days really
trying to give context to connor about
what alisoft has done
yeah i just zoned so i don't know if
there's any games like that
are famous outside of japan that also
basically alisoft is like one of the
oldest i guess like most well-known in
the era gay world
yeah um there's like illusion like alice
soft um
[ __ ] what a leaf uh leaf
yeah you should name it pokemon leaf uh
you know maple is another maker my
favorite pokemon type maple lump of
sugar is another one there's like
basically it's like it's it's basically
just like an og
uh irrigated developer yeah and they
came out with a new game that looks
completely different to anything that
they've done okay right so i've played a
few like a
soft games back in my mind wait what
what the [ __ ] do you do in a narrow game
explain to me it's a visual novel a
visual novel with porn
jack hartford if it's good
[Laughter]
connor's like wait how can you get off
how does that work so like
if it's good you're like basically think
of it as it's like
perfectly halfway between jacking off to
a dojin and jacking off to a hammer i
can't imagine
how the latter the former feels i
basically
it's like jacking off to a dojin but the
audio from the hentai is playing
okay yeah so there's voice acting and
there's sound effects so it's it's
dubbed doujins
dubs dojo that can also be autoplayed
yeah so like you
you're playing this story game and you
might say you just beat one out and then
you just
carry on yeah
i sit there for like you know 30 seconds
after i'm done and i just look at
disgust
at what i've been talking
because right after it you are in like a
heightened state of like
you're basically like a monk for 30
seconds where you're like i will never
have sex
ever well i'm not i don't know like i'm
like turn the show you get post not
regret
a hundred percent every time every time
and then i'm like
that's weak will with my [ __ ] with
porn now
if i could abandon porn i would you know
you just never need to masturbate ever
again i'd be like sure why not
let's try it let's see how it goes have
you ever completed no november
no i've never attempted it well you
should well it sounds like you're you're
wanting to attempt it right now you
should just because you'll end up
getting like a wet dream eventually
right like that'll happen right if you
don't
yeah well if you leave it for a month
yeah
when was the last time you didn't jack
off for a month well never but that's
because
exactly but that's because for whatever
that's because i'm not going to [ __ ]
spew [ __ ] being like i can live with
that point like no no no no i want i
want porn no i want to i want to live
without it i don't want to be
i don't this is this is the literally i
don't want to be horny i want it
like i've ever seen in real life i hate
being distracted from what i'm trying to
do
and it's just distracting i look at that
meme and i'm just like i want both
really i want to be horny and happy so
you just
you know you just so you see this as
like a distraction from your optimized
life
yeah exactly pretty much yeah my
optimized lifestyle is being ruined by
this
oh my god so i can never hear the word
optimized in the same way
after this [ __ ] podcast so you're
you're playing this
game you know yeah yeah it's a game how
is it a [ __ ] game it's reading
it's tricking you in a jackpot no
because this alisoft one has like
full-on jrpg elements as well
oh so you're like you're in the middle
of a battle and you're trying to jack
off
no no no no so the jack okay so what are
the jrpg elements
okay so think okay this is i hate the
fact that i'm using this as an example
think of persona oh god here we go
persona
in my opinion persona games are the
perfect
blend of visual novel and jrpg where
like they've somehow managed to make
two like elements of two completely
different styles of games
and mix it perfectly right so in persona
the jrpg elements
are most often than not completely
separated from the actual
visual novel elements right in persona
yeah in persona
whereas what well what's a visual novel
we just get a
earthquake i don't know if i just felt a
small jig well it's probably this
okay so in person so in persona right
like the
you have the visual novel elements and
then you have the jr in between the yeah
yeah so like you know you'd have like
you go through a dungeon or whatever and
then you know
once once you complete that dungeon then
it goes into the visual level
yeah yeah well yeah as you call it i
mean i would argue that the grpg
elements are filler for you as well but
regardless right so you know you have
like the story elements and you have
like the actual like gameplay
the the sex scenes times start to happen
during only the visual novel elements
hmm okay so so the the vision of
elements of the sex scenes and the
gameplay stuff breaks up that
so like you're playing so like so like
the standard error like a standard arrow
game that doesn't have jrpg on the heart
it's basically just a visual novel with
sex scenes put into it yeah right
so it kind of intuits with the story
with this one it's just that
separately it has a jrpg portion as well
that is what do you mean like you battle
like what are you doing
like what i'm confused what are you
doing well yeah what the [ __ ] else do
you do in a jrpg so you're just
so it's just a deadass a normal jrpg
game where you're going around battling
monsters leveling up yeah
and then it cuts to like a visual novel
with [ __ ]
yeah who comes up with things like this
i'm looking at this on like conor
slightly i can literally hear the gears
like turning in his head
and it's just not computing it's just
like wait why
the gears are not like they're not
they're not coming they're just stuck
right now i'm just like
this sounds to me right this is the
equivalent of being like so it's a food
tray that jacks you off it's like i
don't want those two things going near
each other what are you talking about
like
those two elements the jrpg game and
then just a visual novel with pawn on it
are like just two elements that just
shouldn't be involved at all why not
why why would they why wouldn't you want
the children okay
look don't look at like you're thinking
about it as
if like there's the visual novel like
storytelling part and then the
sexy and then immediately and then
immediately there's a battle that's not
how it works
how does it work then it it works as if
like there's the
storytelling element the visual novel
element and in the middle
there is a sex scene so it's sandwiched
between the visual novel elements okay
so there's the visual novel elements
where they're telling a [ __ ] story
and there's pawn in the middle
and then it just cuts to when when
they're done with the talking
it just goes to a normal dead ass game
yeah
what why does this sound good to you am
i insane this sounds awful
it sounds great no it doesn't you're
just playing devil's advocate
no no no i'm sorry okay i've i mean i've
i say this as someone who
has also played aero gaze before and
there's there's something
there's something about like hentai
games and aerogas where
the sex scenes feel like there's there's
something different
about feeling like you've earned a sexy
oh [ __ ]
right 100 you know what i mean 100
agree it is it is like you could have
the most mediocre sex scene
but you feel like you've earned that and
it's even more so in this game because
like
you can unlock certain sex scenes
depending on what you do in the jrpg
like a person who watches a hentai i
don't want i don't want an xbox
achievement
i want a hentai achievement a person who
watches a hentai and skips straight to
15 or 20 minutes will not know what
we're talking about i prefer the story
in hentai but i don't want to
sit there and read a [ __ ] book and
then jack off into the book and then
wipe the [ __ ] off my hand and go around
my rpg world leveling up my character
right i don't want to [ __ ] deal with
it oh no like look don't get me wrong
like this is the statement this is not
the type of game for anybody
this isn't like [ __ ] i completely
understand that the stuff i like
in hindsight is pretty [ __ ] yeah this is
like you know what i said i don't
eat where you [ __ ] right this is like
eating the [ __ ] that you're sleeping
like this is like
this is so [ __ ] like this shouldn't be
a combination of things like
only japan would make something like
this because this is so
stupidly like like this shouldn't exist
well that's not true like look at
honeypot
yeah that was yeah that was made by
americans yeah i don't [ __ ] like
honeypop
i enjoy honeypot thank god because it's
literally what i just
because because because like i for
example
was that like bejeweled or some [ __ ]
wasn't that game like it was one of
those [ __ ]
it was like it's like a puzzle game yeah
it's a puzzle game i don't want a puzzle
game that i jack off to
but no no because the thing is the thing
is it's like jacking off to a jigsaw
puzzle being like oh
oh it's making porn the pieces are
making a pawn out yeah you wonder
because the thing is the thing is right
you have this gameplay loop right you
have this gameplay luke but
unlike you i need a reward for playing
this game
i need a reward for playing this game
unlike you i don't jack off the xbox
most of the time
xbox achievements either most of the
time it
has to be story most of the time that's
that's why i play games if i have a
gameplay loop
you can have the best [ __ ] gameplay
loop of all time
if there's no motivation for me to play
it then i'm just going to not play
that's why i don't give a [ __ ] about
most games that don't have a story
because it's like what's the
why am i playing this yeah there's there
are so many games that i agree have
a great gameplay i i can totally agree
with that but why is that porn in it
because that's the reward you get for
playing the game because i'm sorry if
i'm feeling a little horny sometimes
like for example i just can't imagine
holding the xbox controller
and then just all right put it down get
the tissue box out like what
that's insane for example like a game
like for another
degeneracy should not be reached like
first a game like dead cells
which i heard which i which i played and
i was i played it for like five minutes
and i thought this was a really good
game and then i got bored for five
minutes because i was like why am i
playing this game there's no motivation
for me to actually play through levels
it's a nice gameplay loop same with
something like celeste that's amazing
this is an amazing game i went through
one level when i got bored because
i really couldn't care about the story
so there was there was there was like
a man it's so good so addictive but
that's the thing if it had
a reward for me to complete the level
that i would have played through it
there need there needs to be some kind
of what god is saying is that so less
celeste
if every time like if every time i
completed a level celeste there was a
hentai scene or something like that
that's what you literally just want like
gant wants to to have like a bit of
level and then the pornhub music starts
playing that's what gantt wants yes
that's wrong that's i want that dude
you guys are too comfortable imagine
checking imagine
something on the gameplay level of dead
cells or celeste
or something along those lines
masterpiece my masterpiece i'm just
imagining that right now
that would be of that would be a monster
that would be [ __ ] amazing because
like
you know every time you finish a level
of celeste you have such like
[ __ ] yes like moments right it's like
yes i i went through that i died
hundreds and hundreds of times yeah and
now
here is my reward hell yeah that is
gonna be the best jack off you'll ever
have
yeah two two uh i'm not saying make
celeste porn
no no no that's what i'm saying
we don't want to hoot the [ __ ]
characters no no no no no no no no
that's not we're talking we're talking
about if we had a gameplay loop of
something like celeste or something on
that level
and then we had we had it hentai to it
my god
that is improving upon perfection you
people have not how has
no one crowdfund this [ __ ] now i'm
making please i am making
this [ __ ] i am going to put some money
right now give me some money i will make
it happen it's [ __ ] animals like you
of the reason why we have [ __ ] like
minecraft sex scenes
like this is the problem you guys who
want to put [ __ ] porn in everything
have you seen the minecraft porn on
youtube
some of it's kind of hot joey joey like
finishes at level and
it's not even levels in minecraft joey
finishes getting some diamonds and
minecraft just swaps over to the next
tab and starts playing
minecraft do you know how hard it is to
get diamonds in minecraft that's like a
great achievement oh my god man
i can say that publicly because i know
i'm not the only one
who genuinely thinks that the fact that
minecraft porn even
[ __ ] exists means that i am not are
you saying you like minecraft porn no
i'm not
that sounds like you have a problem with
it no i mean i don't care
what this is it's like a kids game
though
i've uh this this podcast has been a
weird one i just think it's sad right
that there are kids out there who
legitimately
like are curious about porn and the
first thing they think is
my two loves steve and minecraft i would
like to see
if they did that to him because it's
only kids watching these things right
because no cattle can jack off to
steve steve block's [ __ ] something
you know i mean
no joey come on come on no i'm not
saying i am but i think i think you
underestimate some
like adults willpower i've okay i i have
what i don't
checked off to minecraft no no i've this
is the first i've ever heard of
minecraft porn
really honest you've never seen i've
never seen
it describe it to me please
youtuber made the video about it but
there was actually like so much like
full-on
traditional pornos like made in
minecraft when when you first mentioned
it i thought
okay we're just being sarcastic i know
there's like
uh what's his name captain sparkles
right one of those like minecraft
animations yeah basically imagine that
but it would literally be like a porno
situation where it was like
someone would be like oh no it's like a
high quality like minecraft image
you're you're [ __ ] that's what i saw and
that was like steve like ramsey
please say something no no no no like
steve like [ __ ] a creeper or something
or something yeah yeah and the creeper
has like tits right yeah yeah yeah
this is legit this is actually we'll we
will show you this is the part
afterwards
if you don't hold back right if you let
your creative juices run wild
on projects like joey wants to do with
all of this [ __ ] this is what happens
and we don't need this we don't need
this we don't need this i don't know
no no don't get me wrong we don't need
it no that's the thing right
people want it no no no it doesn't
matter what people want people don't
deserve what they want i don't know
if it's worth i don't know if it's worse
what i just
imagined in my mind from you describing
it or actually watching the actual thing
we'll show you afterwards and we'll i
don't know maybe jesus can add a clip of
like god reacting to it when we're done
with the episode we'll leave the cameras
rolling yeah
i'm just like this is a [ __ ] post right
it's literally like
it can only be kids watching it yeah
right it's so disturbing that it's just
funny
well i mean it's funny to us but yeah
obviously i'm sure i'm sure
the mother have we reached that age is
this what our parents felt when they
walked in and
saw us like jacking it off to animated
easter eggs is this is this how is this
how
they felt now i mean i'll never forget
the look my parents gave me
what wait you've never had like your
parents like walking on you jacking off
no
i've hit it very well if they have
really yeah again i remember there was
my stairs would creak i had a warning oh
yeah that's right yeah yeah
your parents walked in on you with my my
dad walked on me once
how big was the screen of like this oh
no it's tiny
it meant jacking off on like a gameboy
it was not like you know like my old
like shitty [ __ ] desktop computer
with like i think it was like a 16 inch
or whatever i had a black and white tv
oh really yeah it's kind of black and
white it's like a hand me down and it
could like it couldn't play like v yeah
it's [ __ ] awful so i couldn't put
pawn on that
all right well i can't believe i'm about
to tell this story
here we go oh god i don't even remember
how old i was this is [ __ ] easy it
was it was i remember i don't remember
exactly how old it was but it was around
you know that age
as a teenager when you first discover
porn right yeah like you know
anywhere between like i don't know 13 to
15 something like that
maybe even earlier for some people i
don't know but uh i remember
what it was too i think it was
legitimately the first time
i watched like a hentai on my computer
right
and you went straight to hentai this was
like
this is like not long after i discovered
porn
he quickly got down that rabbit hole
yeah i know like that that first time i
hid
but but the first time with hentai was a
different story
and i was in my room and like my room
has like a had a lock on it
right so i thought i'd lock the door oh
oh no i thought and i i remember it i
remember what we
chanted i was it was a kanojo college of
canada oh
classic classic right classic yeah yeah
yeah all right it's like next to libel
black
yeah yeah and uh and yeah so i was like
oh something has arose
in me
[Laughter]
something has some reason something has
arose
right my little joey has has woke now
right so i was like let's give it a go
and so i did it and then uh i hear like
a a clack
of yeah the door opening and i'd look
around and it's my dad
standing there he's pretty he's pretty
proud of you though no no oh he looked
at me
and he looked at what was on my screen
and he looked at me again and he just
said
really mate
[Laughter]
your dad seems like the most australian
man alive he just
i remember exactly what he said he's
like really mate couldn't have been
regular porn
he's like i wouldn't have i wouldn't
even be disappointed with you it was
just regular porn
and i was like i mean i've i've been
past that point i was kind of
experimenting he's like
all right whatever like i don't know
what i don't know why i have already
gotten bored of regular porn i have i'm
seeking new adventures i could i could
legitimately see the very moment where
the disappointment came you know what i
mean it's like it's like it's like a
certain look in my dad's eyes where it
kind of went from like
whoa what are you doing too oh oh no
he's into that he's into that [ __ ] huh
oh yes father i am into that [ __ ]
are you winning son no
and now i talk about it for a job so
yeah i hope you're proud of me dad
that felt so desperate dad please love
me please
i'm winning now oh my god
i'm finally winning dad it's just that
that moment has carved into you and
you're like you're like the son who just
looks for your dad's approval yeah i
don't have a i don't have a lot of like
distinct memories during my childhood
but that was definitely one that will
like forever stick with me like
it's kind of just implanted itself into
the back of my brain
yeah now i don't know i've never been
caught jacking off at all because to me
it's like
if if if i do this a checklist happens
you know like 100 for me yeah
yeah it's it's it's it's the same way my
sneak unfortunately
it's it's the same when you know you
leave the house and you have your
okay pat keys wallet phone same thing
same thing when you do
the same thing same thing you know
you do you do the deed and you're just
like okay door locked yeah headphones on
or whatever
make sure nobody's in the house or
nobody can hear and then you start
see with the lock on my door i got a
little too overconfident
so i'm like yeah this is this is this
foolproof isn't it and then i just i
guess i just forgot you know what it
felt like it felt like you know when
you're playing pokemon and you like
go into a cave and you put repel on and
it runs out just before you're about to
leave the game
and you get into an encounter that's
what it felt like i was like [ __ ] i was
that close
yeah but i don't know like i've like i i
thought
getting walked in on right yeah is like
a common thing
because you see it so much on the
internet right it's like i got walked in
like what do i do
like you know that kind of stuff so have
you ever walked in on anyone or been
walked in on
oh my god maybe i have i don't know i
feel like these are like buried memories
yeah there's probably a good chance i've
probably walked in on something like i
don't know you've been to parties and
seen [ __ ] but like people just don't
care
that doesn't count they're just like i
mean in like a private time you know
yeah no i don't think i have actually no
yeah i i think i've never walked in on
someone but the closest i've come
is it was in university and i was uh
visiting a mate
and it was like a group house so uh like
two or three of my mates are there
and we were getting ready for the night
out so i was just like saying hello to
everyone
and then um i knock on this i knock on
one of my mate's door
and i you know that panic scramble that
you can hear so his door was locked
right
but i i knock on the door and all i
heard was
[Music]
that's probably what i was doing as well
honestly that's all i heard
right and then he opens the door and the
laptop which is opposite
like where the door is is conveniently
closed
so i'm just like what are we just doing
and it was like nothing i was just uh
just working on my presentation you know
yeah yeah i bet you
i mean you were but uh yeah i've never
actually walked in on anyone but i feel
like
it's more common in america because in
university there if you share a room
that's this is why i can't imagine
that's weird to me this is why i can't
imagine having a roommate
right because how do you how do you
schedule that do you
anyone in america can you ask me do you
do you actually have to schedule
your sessions because like do you have
to be like where are you going
how long will you be at is this just an
urban legend coming back this is like an
urban legend where do
you tell each other where do you like
did you like have like a calendar
where you schedule okay guys okay i'm
circling boys
this time it's my time there's going to
be a sock in the door that's how you
know
and if the sock is on the door then it
is like
code red don't come in never disturb me
during my fact
i mean like i guess like what i want to
ask you guys is like i mean
we none of us have children right yeah
but like hypothetically right why'd you
say it like that
why don't you say it like right right
right right right not the way
up yeah but like hypothetically right
like if you ever like
get a kid for example and you become the
role of the parent and you walked in
on your kid doing that yeah like how
would you guys react like what would you
say
join it i don't know it's
not it's not so it's not really to have
a conversation there you're like sit
down son it's like whoa what am i doing
but i'm sure some parents have right
it's like oh my god i don't know like
what is even like as a parent what's the
correct answer
i probably tell them not to do it really
really because they're gonna do it
anyway
but you don't encourage them be like
watch as much porn as you want son
i feel like my dad said that what the
what
something similar he's just like because
like i i specifically yeah you can get
addicted to porn
right right right but i specifically
remember my dad wasn't so much like
disappointed in the fact that i was like
jacking off at all because it was the
hentai
and you're an adult that's [ __ ]
normal right yeah whatever you're
eventually going to get to this point
it could have been anything else that
you were jacking off to i'd probably
just you know walk out and then the next
time i see
like my child i'd probably just be like
we can just forget about it
right and then because that i i feel
like the more you talk about it
the more the more you put light on it
the worse that they're gonna feel just
just
make it as make it as casual as possible
to be like
i feel so many parents you know end up
doing like the sit down son let's have a
talk
i feel that's the worst answer yeah you
know what i mean because like i i feel
like there's nothing more i mean i never
got
the talk from my parents but i feel if i
ever was in that position i'd be like
[ __ ] did you ever ask your parents where
babies came from probably
right they probably just gave me some
[ __ ] answer yeah
any kid remember i still remember the
[ __ ] answer my mind
yes so i thought
that what literally what she said was
babies came out of the belly button
right
and that's graphic thinking about this
as an adult i think i'm
that's permanently scarred me because
when i see a belly button now
because as a kid as a kid i i had this
disgusting thought of
oh [ __ ] babies crawl out there
and now as a fully grown adult i still
see belly buttons i'm just like
ugh all right all i can think of is that
[ __ ] scene in ace ventura you know
when he's coming out of the [ __ ] like
rhino that's all i can imagine
it's like some alien [ __ ] like looking
back i'd rather my mom
had just tell me graphically where
babies came from well
as as opposed to just tell me yeah they
crawl out the belly button because i
remember
i remember the first time like there's
there's two moments that have scarred me
for life one was that and the second
time was the first time i saw the matrix
where matrix yeah the matrix what scene
there's a scene
where have you guys seen the matrix yeah
i can't imagine a scene
okay so there's a way i think i know
which one there's a scene
as well yeah that there's a scene where
the agents pin neo down
and then uh like a spidery shrimp
like emerges and then it crawls it it
crawls up his belly button yeah i saw
that
yeah and that [ __ ] me up so badly
because i'm just like
it okay i remember it it reinforced that
it was possible for things to go
in or out of the belly button so i'm
just like protect this at all costs
yeah i thought it was like some you know
alien burst out sheer wear just like
you know i i i had a similar thing with
the with uh the mummy
you know when like the beetle is like
crawling uncles oh my god that was the
first time i
like physically was like i'm scared i
feel like yeah that magic scene i
blocked out my mind
yeah because i remember being i remember
watching that like a ten-year-old and
being disgusted
yeah oh god it's awful but yeah i mean
that's that's a tangent right from porn
yeah yeah i don't know if i might cause
my kid do it yeah i'd probably be like
well did you do it efficiently did you
mean max's son
how much time did you spend 30 minutes
you're in there that's way too long you
cannot get in the habit of doing that
son
i don't know because like when you see
the like people
talking about like i legit would worry
if my kid got like addicted to porn
oh yeah if you hear about the adults you
get addicted to porn like terry crews
was addicted to porn right
was he yeah he was addicted to pawn i
think um and there was generally
i sent you a link so i i was on youtube
and there was just a video and it was
something called like coming clean or
something
remember it and it was just this guy who
was just like no one
no one had exposed him on youtube no one
had said anything he just came out with
it he was just like
i'm addicted to porn guys i'm going
broke because he's like i
had a few million and he was just like i
spent yeah oh i do remember that yeah
it was that guy who was in like a happy
relationship he was married wasn't he
happily married
and he was he wasn't like uh it was like
a buff
really good-looking dude good-looking
yeah i
and he was just like yes so like i'm
just like horribly addicted to porn
girls yeah he just spent his money on
chatterbait yeah yeah i just felt so
bad for the dude and it's like you know
had this like come out any other way
people probably would have mocked him
but he
you know he spoke about it himself and
you kind of felt like really bad for the
dude because you're like
i can't i i can't sympathize per se i
would not sympathize i
i can't ex you know experience that
myself but like i was like [ __ ] dude i
would never want that on my kid or
something oh yeah to be like cripplingly
addicted
to like virtual video porn right
whatever i don't know i feel so bad
about that i think it especially hurts
considering the fact that like he's
going broke because of it yeah
and luckily the guy like [ __ ] like the
video is really good i recommend
watching it just to like i don't know
and
his wife was like understanding of it
and they she helped like walk him
through it actually was really [ __ ]
sweet and i hope the guy is doing better
now i've i
have no idea i didn't watch any of the
videos but like how do you
even get to a point when you realize
it's scary like what what
what is it what is the line what is your
porn addiction what what is what is
a porn addiction you know it's is it
snap
she's gonna kill me for that joke yeah
it's like is it to the point where it's
like you're spending so much money that
it's like
putting a dent on youtube i can't ever
spend money on porn yeah ever well i
mean
i i mean i slide forward like yeah you
[ __ ] off yeah i mean i just recently
bought narratives
i i can hand on heart say i've never
spent any money on porn i feel like that
is like a big
line to cross where you're comfortable
getting your credit card out
yeah to put in right that's like just a
lie i don't want to cross yeah and i'd
be really [ __ ] sad at my son
or my daughter if i they were like
you've got a premium browser
subscription like why
why yeah i don't know what it like to me
spending money on like hentai games or
something
like completely understandable as soon
as
you spend money on like i guess real
life porn for some reason that just
flips a switch me to be like how why i
think it's because they're like
unlike arrogance and like hentai and
stuff like that there are
so many options to get the same
experience for free
that's it right because i've i'm
guessing none of us have ever
actually bought a hentai dvd or a hentai
knife ah well
i did really i did oh oh oh okay
okay i bought uh the classic i bought
mother nose breasts
did you actually i actually bought it
yeah i bought a physical coffee because
i after the podcast
yeah yeah it hasn't arrived yet oh i
bought it because i was like
i noticed that the licenser who's
selling it uh they
eventually de-list their older ones and
i thought well i gotta get a copy of
mother knows brass just in case it goes
yeah but
that doesn't count because you've
already seen it i'm not gonna jack off
to it it's gonna be pristine
yeah you bought that as a meme right
this is to preserve
this is this is the [ __ ] you're going to
frame and you're going to be you're
going to show your kids and be like kids
cost me
fifty dollars yeah well but like that's
understandable right like no one's gonna
[ __ ] frame their brazos subscription
on a wall right
yeah it's like i mean there are people
out there but
because it's like uh you know you hear
about those you know they'd be like
politician scandals and they'd be like
he spent forty thousand dollars on porn
i'm like
i don't even know how you would do that
how do you start to spend that much
money
on porn i don't even know how you go
about that how do you
what i want to know is how do you not
have enough sources of porn that you
need to spend money on i think a lot of
people want like specific porn
right like i think again like this is
where a lot of like independent creators
come no
that's that's totally the reason why i
only found this thing because i i feel
like i would never pay 20 dollars
for for something i'm going to jack off
to right yeah i mean like
for me for me like i can't i can't
understand why people would want to
support independent creators like for
example only fans or something because
you know you there there is that power
social relationship in there and i can
totally understand
why people would want to spend money on
that um i don't understand
like browser's subscriptions or just
like where there is no parasitoid
there is no parasocial relationship
whether i would almost argue that
only fans in all those parasocial
relationships are way worse off than
getting a breath
totally i agree with you
it is a dangerous line i don't even like
dislike
anything about it i just feel sad when i
look at it all like i just feel sorry
for everyone like i mean other than
the creators are making bank right good
for them like totally yeah
understandable
the grind you do what you got to do yeah
but like when you look at some of these
guys and you see what some of them say
online like you just feel sad for them
yeah yeah
just like that this isn't to demerit any
like no not workers or anything like
that with
this thing a lot of the stuff they make
is [ __ ] awesome and a lot you put a
lot of work into exactly
like i just feel it's it's it's a
dangerous line that
i don't want to cross i don't want to go
into that because if you st if you pay
for juan i feel like
you'll do it again like yeah i'll
probably buy another one
and it's dangerous for the creator as
well because then you get you know some
of these supporters who get a little too
comfortable with it
and try and start crossing like i can't
imagine i can't imagine what they have
to deal with on the day
and they get huge huge respect to them
every type of like creepy dude you know
thinking that just because they paid
like a grandiose amount of money to this
creator that yeah
suddenly they're like best friends you
know yeah i mean that's just not how i
follow
a few of them on twitter it's pretty
good to see like oh god what do you see
but like just seeing what they get up to
is like it i mean it's sad some of the
[ __ ] they got to deal with
just to like you gotta like fight just
to take to have people take you
seriously
yeah yeah oh my god yeah because the
thing is i would like to think that
everyone's end goal for watching porn
is like you know an offset for being
able to go into like a happy
relationship where you just feel
satisfied and um and like happy with
abandon your life
you know you you stop wanting to be
horny and you just be happy yeah yeah
you know what i'm saying abandon horny
be happy and i feel like
if you go out and pay for porn you're
crossing a dangerous line
where i've no return right not not that
you can't return from here but
you're you're getting comfortable it may
not be dangerous i just perceive it to
myself
yeah that's that i mean that this is
this is it sounds dangerous
everyone has everyone has a different
line this is my line as well where
if i go out and cross this line it's the
line that i'm
not comfortable with myself being about
and you know some people are comfortable
and i'm sure there's
healthy people out there who you know
have i'm sure
there's something with the addiction
thing right like it's like 95 95
people are totally capable of
self-regulating
and not over consuming things but
there's a good amount of people out
there where they find that one thing
that just like breaks them
yeah they just can't stop yeah like it's
just what it is yeah and it's just we go
back to the point of
how do you recognize what what point is
too far
is it when your life is being actively
ruined or
when you just can't find a happy
relationship you know yeah which is like
again why like going back to that video
like massive props to the dude for being
able to like stop himself and be like
you know what this is getting out of
hand
like realizing that it's important yeah
yeah and yeah you know honestly
like i i to me i was just amazed that he
was willing to talk about that publicly
and you know to me i was like damn
that's like that's like pretty [ __ ]
big balls to come out and be like listen
guys
i'm addicted to poor knowing that people
are going to meme you yeah but in in
reality you know there's probably a lot
of people going through that and i have
massive respect for the guy coming out
and i think i remember as well like from
what i saw hardly anything
all the comments are really positive
yeah yeah well because it's it's again
like
when the stuff is sensitive people don't
want to talk about it because they meme
it but
it's really important to have people
come out and be like listen this is a
real thing
like it's [ __ ] me over yeah
absolutely it's the exact same thing
with
for example gacha addiction you know we
can meme the [ __ ] out of it but if
someone has an issue
some you should take it seriously and
you shouldn't just
think that people are going to mock you
and meme the [ __ ] out of you some people
addiction to anything is never good some
people will but the good people out
there will actually understand
that you know you can have an
embarrassing problem sometimes
uh sometimes it's hard to tell when
you've gone too far
yeah like joey plays arrow games you
know like i feel sorry for him
oh good for you dude on my n a account
though i've helped either
okay okay got it i'm clean i'll tell you
he was also clean
all our patrons right here the most
amazing segway in the history of the
show
i i would like to say a shout out to
this particular patron for being
wonderful
look at a girl why this one why why that
one ah because
why not why not wow by the way what
flavor g fuel you guys drinking i'm
drinking
i finished it because it was just so
delicious but i had the uh pink lemonade
it's actually really really good the
things mary
berry drinking gone i am drinking the
pewdiepie flavor you're drinking
pewdiepie juice yes i
am jealous well i hope you guys have
enjoyed this
this is one of one of the weirdest
segments like we just had so many
varying topics jesus christ hey you guys
had hey we actually talked about anime
for once
for like the majority of this podcast
two weeks in a row yeah disgusting i'm
not talking about anime for
four months now i'm done but if you guys
like to follow us over on twitter we
also have a subreddit post us your memes
there and also listen to us on spotify
if you hate our faces hopefully once
this episode aired
we would have reached a hundred thousand
members in our reddit which
that's crazy would be absolutely awesome
what are you doing don't join the
redditor
yeah stop wasting your time do you know
how much meme potential there was in
this episode alone
i will review your memes eventually
again meme review let's go
but anyway i've been gig up with the
boys this has been trash taste
and we'll see you guys next time bye bye
bye
so bonus scene they're about to show me
minecraft for and obviously we can't
show this on youtube
but you can show my reaction so
i don't know oh i'm on like x videos
okay oh yeah that one that one i think
like if it's minecraft porn on youtube
does that is that really porn
oh my god that's vile i haven't seen
that one
yeah this is the one i saw where i was
just like okay this is going too far
okay you go play that i've got the audio
can you can you hold it so that i can
watch this right now i want to see what
you're watching okay can we
do do i have to make sure it's like
muted no no it'll be fine it's muted
don't worry it won't come up in the
microphone
what the [ __ ] this is the one i saw this
is the one i saw
what the [ __ ]
what right it's like it's like an mmd
right
there's an enderman there watching yeah
oh is he gonna start oh
oh is he gonna get in what oh my god
what why does it look like that
oh wait the enderman just came out with
this like ended actually great animation
i know right
oh my god there's a point of me there's
a vov
what the [ __ ] oh
oh oh oh
wait
is that anal is this anal right now oh
my god
this this anime why is animation this
good
why is it this good
that's great i can't i can't look away
but that's [ __ ] oh
it's like how many views what no
no this just got this is when full
hentai
oh it's the [ __ ] stomach bulge and
everything
this went this way like full on like
karina i think i've seen enough
oh i'm satisfied i've seen enough i'd
rather watch ork gangbangs right now
i mean you basically just did
i am just i if i walked into my son
watching that i would be disappointed
i'm telling you i'm sorry by the way
we just watched one minute 30 out of an
eight and a half minutes how many views
does i have
it's on x videos 600 000 views nice
[Music]
you